So Leute da bin ich, heute machen wir mal was was ich nicht gedacht hätte, dass ich
das in nächster Zeit noch mal mache.
Und zwar wir spielen tatsächlich Battlefield Season 1, äh Battlefield 2042 Season 1.
Mal schauen, also ich hab zur Mittag schon ein paar Runden gespielt, ich glaub drei Runden,
die neue Map ist ganz ok, zum Glück kann man die neue Map quasi in Schleife spielen
und muss sich den alten Krempel nicht geben, die neue Map ist echt ok, die neue Map ist
wirklich nicht schlecht, also muss man sagen, ich finde das ist die beste Battlefield 2042
Map, allerdings ist es trotzdem ein bisschen zu groß, ein bisschen zu lang alles, Gachibas,
aber es ist, es ist besser, ich meine es ist jetzt nicht Battlefield 4 Niveau, oder besser
gesagt nicht BC2, Battlefield 3 Niveau, äh Battlefield 4 war finde ich von den Maps ja
gerade für Rush auch schon nicht gut, wobei es Conquest Map ist, aber ansonsten also,
es ist halt nix drin, es ist Season 1 und es gibt nix, Season 1 hat eine Map, ein Specialist,
ein Specialist wollte wahrscheinlich kaum eine haben und eine nennenswerte Waffe, das
zweite ist eine Armbrust, also ich weiß ja nicht, egal wir schauen uns das, wir schauen
uns das ganz an, ich sag fünf Minuten, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal, Serious Max willst
spielen, Pepega Aim, oder hast du nicht installiert, also falls jemand der halbwegs brauchbar ist,
ja wie du willst, wie du willst, also falls jemand Bock hat, der halbwegs brauchbar ist
im Battlefield, ganz alleine ist immer Sack richtig, also falls jemand Bock hat, wen hatten
wir letztens dabei, wir hatten doch letztens, also letztens, letztens, es ist über ein halbes,
es ist acht Monate her, wo ich das letzte Mal gespielt hab, hatten wir doch so einen
richtig krassen Owner dabei aus dem Stream, und es war nicht Captain Peng und es war nicht
Captain Pogger, es war nicht Serious Max, ohne euch zu nahe treten zu wollen, wir hatten
irgendeinen, der richtig krass abging, ich hab vergessen wie er heißt, was für ein Setup
hast du eigentlich auf der armen Windows Laptop mit Ubuntu VM, ne, ich hab ne Ubuntu VM in
meinem VM bei Workstation, ja es gibt Leute die haben sich Gold gekauft, ja ich glaube
ich hab mir sogar auch Gold gekauft, oder ich hab mir nicht die teuerste Version gekauft,
weil ich blöd war, wobei ich hab mir die gar nicht gekauft, ich hab die zum Glück ja bekommen
damals, ich glaub das war ohne Scheiß, ich glaub nach meinen Videos war das das letzte
Mal, dass die mir irgendwas gegeben haben, auf der anderen Seite, nächstes Mal geht
der Werbetrain wieder los, da kommen sie wieder an, ohne Scheiß, wollen wir uns mal den Battle
Pass, Leute wir gucken uns den Battle Pass an, ich hab heute Morgen schon irgendwie drei
vier Sachen anlocken, das ist für alles absolut, absolut keck weh, Leute wisst ihr, ich hab
grad die, die Emote Idee, es gibt Lull und es gibt keck weh, warum verbinden wir das
nicht zu keckl, gibt es, gibt es keckl als Emote schon, keckl, ffz, keckl gibt es, und
ich dachte ich hab die krasse Idee, alter, es gibt keckl schon, ich adde keckl jetzt,
einfach weil ich die Idee hatte, wir machen jetzt, komm, da hat es jemand anderes schon
gemacht, jetzt wird keckl geattet, okay, keckl ist am Start, einfach kurz die Klimaanlage
ausschalten, es bläst so, das ist dann für die Augen nicht gut, so, also, Ark ist heute
for free, ist egal, ich hab Ark vor fünf Jahren oder so gekauft, auf Steam und nie gespielt,
also, schauen wir mal, ich muss kurz, ich muss kurz Game Capture umschalten, nicht wundern,
das ist kurz lag, das ist normal, wer ist denn da gerade on von meinen Leuten, die ich
in der Freundesliste hab, Zack, wer ist das, äh, wer ist das denn, ich hab seriously keine
Ahnung mehr, ein Anime Fan, ajajaja, ähm, der gute alte Opa Peitscher, 69 ist auch am
Start, okay, dann ist alles gut, okay, nicht wundern, Leute, es lag jetzt ganz kurz, bis
ich die Aufnahmequelle umgeschaltet hab, ich kann die Aufnahmequelle aber erst umschalten,
bis das Spiel gestartet ist, weil Battlefield und so, ja, also nicht, nicht wundern jetzt,
startet es heute noch mal, Game, ah, yes, okay, das aus, das an, okay, Battlefield lässt
sich nicht Capture, ist auch gut, vielleicht muss ich es erst aufmachen, ah, das lädt
noch, lässt es sich jetzt Capture, jetzt Capture, okay, exellent, exellent, so, Chico muss mal
kurz weg, den Chat lass ich, aber Chico, Chico mach ich mal aus dem Bild, wir müssen jetzt
gleich Lautstärke testen und sowas, mal kurz die Musik aus, so, wir testen, wir testen
mal kurz, wir testen mal kurz die Lautstärke, also, Warfare, Keuchmisch, Dankeschön für
den Massive-Rate hier, also, probieren wir das ganze doch mal aus, Exposure Conquest,
genau, also, das ist 24,7, die neue Map, ich dachte, die neue Map heißt Retreat oder so,
ah, Exposure in Form von, dass man das vorstellt, 128 Player, seriously, kann man das nicht
in, ich will das, ich will kein 128 Spieler, Leute, kann man das nicht vielleicht mit weniger
Spieler spielen, Select Game Mode, nee, nee, ach, das geht ja nicht, äh, ähm, das ist
total geil, es gibt ja kein Map-Selector, ne, that's how it work out sometimes, oder
wie auch immer, äh, wie kommt man noch mal in Portal, so, nee, also, anscheinend, muss
ich das, haben die nicht was gesagt, sie ist in Breakthrough Training, ja, aber Breakthrough
ist ja nicht die neue Map, Breakthrough ist alles, also, im Prinzip, wir werden jetzt
gezwungen, 128 Spieler zu spielen, weil ansonsten können wir die neue Map wahrscheinlich nicht
spielen, na, geil, top, was, was sagt uns das Ding hier, was, acquire initial rewards
once they rank up, ja, ja, macht jemand, 128 Player, da machst du nix, so, wir müssen
gucken, Leute, ihr müsst mir gleich sagen, ob es ruckelt, ob das Sound passt, vielleicht
läuft das Spiel ja mittlerweile etwas performanter und es ruckelt nicht so heftig, Bild zu laut,
das Problem bei 128 Spieler ist, das ist halt total, in meinem Battlefield war es schon
immer ein bisschen random, aber halt, das ist total random, ich hab das ja vorher schon
ein paar Runden gespielt, manchmal hast du richtig geiles Streaks und manchmal hast du
halt reingeschissen, ja, und Fahrzeuge ist halt auch mega heftig, gerade auf der Map
draußen mit den Helis, du musst eigentlich gar nicht draußen rumlaufen, und wisst ihr,
was ich witzig finde, wenn es dann Helipiloten gibt, die sich darüber aufregen, dass die
Leute die Helis runter geiern, oder aber zu allen sagen, oh hier, kack Noobs, die können
ja nix so, ist auch geil, so, ich geh einfach mal die rein und lass mich von irgendeinem
Heli wegbumsen, Alpa Gatchi, Lautstärktest, Sekunde, geht oder, ist glaube ich ganz okay,
ist zu laut, ist zu laut, wartet mal, bisschen zu laut, dann machen wir einfach so, ich würde
ja gern meinen Ton kontrollieren, ja ich glaub, ein ticken lauter können wir noch machen,
es ist laggy, es laggt, wirklich, es darf nicht laggen, ich hab Game Capture an, ist
nicht laggy, ich muss jetzt Leute, ich muss jetzt auf dem Handy gucken, ob es laggy ist,
ohne Scheiß, ich hab nur mit diesem Spiel Probleme, das ist absoluter Wahnsinn, achso,
wenn ich raus tabbe, ist laggy, ja, das ist normal, das ist Battlefield, da muss man sich
nicht wundern, also das Battlefield 242, da muss man sich nicht wundern, so, ich guck
mir das jetzt mal vor, schau auf meinem Handy an, weil da weiß ich das auf jeden Fall,
auf Max Schieß, ich muss mir kurz meinen eigenen Stream angucken, weil die Vorschau nicht richtig
funktioniert mit dem Game, ja, na, das ist doch eigentlich okay, man kann das durchaus,
man kann das durchaus noch ein ticken lauter machen, okay, also Leute, wenn irgendwer mitspielen
will, sagt Bescheid, wo bin ich, wo bin ich, ist das ein Fahrstuhl, okay, keine Ahnung,
Map D1, na dann, don't be sad, Leute, was ist der cringiest Operatorspruch, also ich
bin ja für Angel does it again, ich weiß nicht warum, aber irgendwie finde ich den
besonders schlimm, alle, ja, das ist wohl wahr, gehts hier hoch, gehts hier runter, man
weiß es nicht, beides vielleicht, komm mal hier, krasse Utility Use mit Smokegranate,
da ist einfach nur schwarz, man sieht einfach gar nichts, ah, da ist meine Smoke, aus Smoke
ist das massive Fallfedder Kram, so, also es gibt nur eine gute Pose auf der Map und
das ist da oben auf dem Dach, da hinten auf dem Dach, ansonsten kannst du es klicken,
Boris, Boris, du leckst, Achtung, Craple, Massive Craple, komm mal, die Helis ficken
schon wieder alles weg, es ist übrigens auch ziemlich random, ob man auf diesen Klippen
laufen kann oder nicht, Achtung, Achtung, Six-Header-Time, Six-Header-Time, wir sind
schon drinnen, ich wollte jetzt, ich wollte den mega Huge Massive Flank machen, hat aber
nicht funktioniert, oh, oh, da vorne kommt was, den aimen wir jetzt mal einfach ganz
frech ab, unten ist was, ah, da hinten sind sie am Start, gehen wir mal rüber, ich kann
nur Webster spielen, alles andere ist Pains Champ, lebt der noch, lebt der noch oder ist
der dead, Top, Achtung, wenn der noch lebt, oh der lebt nicht mehr, nice, ich check halt
gar nicht wo es lang geht, ja, Pepega aimed, Alter, ich bin da fünf Gegner und dann Hipfire
gesprayt, nichts getroffen, Massive Five-Header-Play, ok, es ist alles flüssig, habe ich gesehen,
passt, richtig Pepega aimed, ach guck mal, wir haben C, das ist doch schön, einmal schön
durch den Bash geklitscht, ja wie gesagt, ich finde es die beste Map, im Vergleich zu
den Base-Games natürlich, nicht insgesamt, die beste Map insgesamt, schwer zu sagen,
was ist die beste Battlefield Map insgesamt, es gibt viele gute, da muss man auf jeden
Fall unterscheiden ob Conquest oder Rush, guckt zu euch an hier da drüben, also es ist auf
jeden Fall nicht Metro und es ist auch nicht, wie heißt diese Metro aus Battlefield 4, da
oben kommt was geflohen, Alter Game please, ich will einfach da hoch, ist da oben noch
was, ach keine Ahnung, ich stelle es an C rum, an C ist der einzig sinnvolle, oh hinter
mir ist ein Panzer, hallo, hallo please, schreckt, ist geil wie genau SMGs sind ne, oh hier ist
viel, hier ist glaube ich einiges, nein, nein, nein, Achtung, Achtung, den Chebaten wir jetzt,
den Chebaten wir richtig, richtig, richtig Chebatet wird er jetzt, pass auf, huge Chebat,
oh ok, dachte, ich dachte der kommt raus, macht er aber nicht, Erika Harbour, ja Erika Harbour
ist ganz gut in Conquest, ich mochte ehrlich gesagt Erika Harbour Rush nicht, ach klar
natürlich, da kommt halt gleich was von hinten und Gutsheet mir in den Bobbes, oh ja nice,
Alter, darfst auch keinem zeigen, dreimal vorbei, hier Lasso, oh was ist da hinter mir,
es ist so vertikal schon wieder, dass du keine Ahnung hast wo es ist, übrigens der Sound
ist immer noch sehr, hallo, please klettern, sehr, sehr merkwürdig, ok hier ist nix, was
jetzt, wie, kann das sein, dass die uns richtig krass fertig gemacht haben, 433 zu 0, ich meine
ich hab schon mehr gesehen, aber das ist schon, ich spiele 18 Minuten Battlefield, also wie
gesagt jetzt ich gucke gerade in den Chat, will irgendjemand mitmachen, am besten jemand
den ich schon mal geedit habe, irgendwann, Tainser, danke für den Sub, ich weiß nicht
wie lange ich das durchhalte, 1-2 Stunden maximal, ich finde die Map gut, ne das mit den Sprüchen
haben sie, doch, doch die Sprüche kommen noch, also am Anfang hat Webster schon irgendwas
von Mount Everest erzählt, in-game Chat, wieso, was ist los, yeah one of the best so far,
was, ich hab, ich konnte jetzt, man kann den Chat, ah doch hier, was wollen sie, nice man,
one of the best, ja das ist richtig, das ist tatsächlich die beste Map, aber es ist jetzt
ja nicht so als wäre die Messlatte unglaublich hoch gewesen, jetzt mal ehrlich, was gibt's
für gute, was gibt's für gute Maps im Base Game, die Containermap ist halbwegs brauchbar,
der Leudoscope ist komplett Trash finde ich, das ist die neue Map, es gibt nur die neue
Map, leider nur mit 128 Spielern, bockt das Game Season 1 wieder, ich kann dir empfehlen
wenn du es gekauft hast, spielst ein paar Runden, weil in spätestens 1-2 Wochen ist die Sache
eh gelaufen wieder, soll der Typ in deutscher darstellen, nee das ist glaub ich ein Engländer
von der Story her, sie wollen weg von 128, ja die einzige Playlist die es gibt, wo es
die neue Map gibt ist 128, aber das was DICE sagt und das was DICE macht sind ja unterschiedliche
paar Schuhe, die haben ja auch gesagt, das ist ein Love Letter to the Fans oder sowas,
ja das Problem ist bei 128 Spieler auch was du bei den Maps gut siehst, du musst die
Maps ja groß machen, aber trotzdem klumpt sich alles, deswegen hast du halt riesen Laufwege
und Clusterfuck, du hast quasi mit 128 Spieler das Negative aus beiden Welten, ja das stimmt,
wieder gibt es eh wenig, achso wir wollen uns den Battle Pass angucken, erinnert mich
mal dran wir gucken uns den Battle Pass an, da könnt ihr mal eine Runde cacken, oh nein
cringe, es tut so weh das anzuhören, achja übrigens guckt euch mal den schönen Spawn
Bildschirm an, guckt mal wie toll der Spawn Bildschirm ist, passt mal auf, ich denk mir
so ein Heli fliegen will ich nicht, eigentlich will ich nur warten bis ich reinspawnen kann
an A1 oder B1 oder so, da unten ist übrigens eh Sack und da oben ist nie einer und hinten
auch nicht wirklich, also eigentlich bist du im Prinzip die ganze Zeit hier so in der
Map, also da haben sie schon was richtig gemacht, warum es das Intro immer noch dauerhaft gibt
ich weiß es nicht, die denken sich die Map Intros sind sehr sinnvoll, dieses Einfliegen
habe ich schon im letzten in Modern Warfare nicht verstanden, übrigens die haben alle
keine Animationen, guckt euch mal an, das Einfliegen habe ich schon in Modern Warfare
nicht verstanden, ich meine das ist ein Respawn Shooter und die fliegen uns ein mit dem Heli,
es gibt zwei Varianten wie man das erklären will, entweder man ist immer ein neuer Soldat,
warum wird man da nicht wieder eingeflogen oder man scheißt drauf und lässt den Heli
einfach weg, achja übrigens eigentlich wisst ihr eigentlich was man machen muss, eigentlich
muss man sich direkt redeployen am Anfang der Runde und warten bis man irgendwo gescheites
rein spawnen kann, es irritiert mich übrigens immer noch, dass man nicht richtig spotten
kann, ah Mist, nein, ok man kanns ja mal probieren, die haben übrigens irgendwas an der Fallschirmsteuerung
geändert, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was, aber irgendwas ist anders als zu dem was
ich letztes Mal gespielt habe, ich bin mir, vielleicht wie der Fallschirm automatisch
wieder aufgeht oder so, irgendwas ist anders, der aimt mich ab, der Dude,
Alter, diese Waffe ist auf Range halt nicht so geil, oh, oh mein, Ammo ist leer, wall
bangen wir mal da rüber, das ist nur Smoke, ich weiß das das nur Smoke ist, selbst outplayed,
selbst outplayed mit dem Smoke, Alter, oh hier gehts was ab, ok das mag ich ja an Battlefield,
das ist kein Scope, Scope ist für Amateure, Ironside Enjoyer ist das wie es ist, das mag
ich ja eigentlich an Battlefield, das ist zwischenzeitlich einfach mal richtig abgeht
alles um dich explodiert, aber irgendwie noch beherrschbar ist meistens, da war das ein
Gegner, tatsächlich, Kegwade, wo kommt denn der her, ich hab nicht so die geile Range,
was zum, ah Schneiber Mensch da drüben, alles klar, Gameplay von Wupploos, ich guck lieber
Maxia, ja geht mir auch so, der Maxia macht das durch Dach da, da oben drauf muss ich,
da oben drauf, oben drauf, beste, beste, Dachstelz, immer Dachstelzen, beste Dachstelz, 2222,
ich weiß jetzt halt nicht sind die oben oder, ok die sind auf jeden Fall im Gang oder hier
im Gang wahrscheinlich, Achtung, S-Jam oder wie nennt man das, oh oh, der Reload ist hot,
ah in der Ass geballert hier, so musst du es machen, Flankerino, hoho, Alter, wie viele,
Leute guck doch mal, so pass mal auf wenn die ganzen Helis rein spawnen sind auf einmal
wieder die 80 plus Kills Leute, ich hab keine Granate dabei, vielleicht nehme ich tatsächlich,
ok wir können nen Sensor mitnehmen, Proxy-Sensor oder ganz stinknormale Frac, alle waren so
am Start ja, also das war glaube ich einer der wenigen Flanks die mal wirklich funktioniert
haben, wow wow wow, was ist hier los, einer der wenigen Flanks die wirklich funktioniert
haben, 128 Spieler die ich erlebt hab bisher, habt ihr gesehen wie die Tests, ok was auch
immer, YOLO, wie wer, hallo, das hat alles nicht gehitted oder was, wollt ihr mir das
wirklich erzählen, das hätte nicht gehitted oder wie, ja, ich trau mich jetzt einfach
mal, wenn die von links kommen bin ich im Arsch, ok, alles klar, ich glaub wir müssen
wieder rein, Alter guckt euch das mal an das sind einfach zu viele Spieler oder 28,
das ist einfach too much, so und jetzt kann ich euch mal zeigen was auch sehr random ist,
nämlich ob das funktioniert mit den Klippen oder nicht, hallo, kann ich das mal nachladen,
da kommt ein Heli, der macht mich gleich platt, guckt mal, das ist sehr random ob das funktioniert
mit den Klippen, mal bleibt man drauf und mal, Alter das sind zu viele, das sind einfach
zu viele, oh nice, ich krieg einen Reds, Reds, Pog Reds, Massive, oh oh, Alter, geschreckt
haben wir sie, Massive Pog, Pog G, da machst du nichts, das sind einfach zu viele, ja,
es sind einfach zu viele, du kannst hier die 5-handigsten, die 5-handigsten Flanks machen
und 3-4 Gegner killen, das sind einfach, das sind einfach zu viele, wenn 3 auf dich gucken
machst du nichts, ja, oh ein Pog aus Reds, hallo, hallo, ha, das Aufstehen ist verbackt,
die droppen da gleich runter, ich sag's euch, Alter, das mit dem Aim, ok, ich wollte gleich
sagen, das mit dem Aim müssen wir nochmal üben, ach da oben ist er, ich könnte eigentlich
gerätzt werden, ich bin komplett safe, jetzt nicht mehr, kann man, kann man umheben, ah
hier Request, helpp, helpp, helpp, guck mal, da sind ganz viele Medics um mich drumrum,
da ist er, da ist er, MVP, ok, jebaited, Mashubas, MVP, ok, da kommt noch mehr gleich, so wir
machen wieder den Flank, jebaited, hat mich richtig jebaited man, ah guck jetzt bin ich
wieder runter gefallen, das ist einfach nur richtiger Sack, also mal funktioniert das
gut, mal funktioniert das richtig gut mit den Klippen und mal halt gar nicht, sag mal
kann das sein, dass wir dich gerade richtig bashen, oh oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Alter,
da war, da war ein Pufftschkieschner oder so, einfach mal blind, einfach Granate machen,
blind, blind rein, hat sogar gehitted, von der Seite, von der Seite, da hinten ist übrigens
die Beleuchtung geklitscht übrigens, ich weiß nicht, die Map ist tatsächlich ganz
gut, guck mal da hinten ist die Beleuchtung geklitscht, seht ihr das, das ist ein Bug,
wenn du da reinläufst geht mit deine Beleuchtung immer heller für drei Minuten oder bis du
respawnst, also das ist, Leute ich trau mich nicht, ah fuck da ist ja keiner von mir, habt
ihr gesehen wie verbugt die Beleuchtung war da hinten, vielleicht ist es auch next level
HDR ja, oder vielleicht rendern die auch über FFmpeg im Browser und das ist einfach verbugt,
ey diese Klippen die machen mich fertig, mal funktioniert der Klippenstelz und mal,
mal nicht, ist nix, das könnt ihr mir nicht erzählen, dass die ersten nicht gehitted
haben, FFmpeg in Wasserm in Electron als Overlay in Battlefield ja, vielleicht war es auch
PP Guard, kann auch sein, oder rein da, rein da, erstmal schön durch die Decke gespawnt,
voll, wo ist denn hier überhaupt was, da ist irgendwo der Eingang, hier ist der Eingang,
irgendwo da, da ist der Eingang, hier, wallbang, nade, unten, zack, ah ist meiner, ok, hier
komm hier irgendwo sind sie doch, gehts hier noch weiter, ah wo könnte, alter was ein
sinnloser Gang, wer baut denn sowas man, einfach komplett sinnloser Gang, wo sind wir, ist ja
auch schön, dass man die Maps sonst nicht richtig verwenden kann, außer dafür, ah da
muss ich rein, übrigens guck mal, ich hab auf C gegangen, C ist da, und was mach ich,
ich spawn einfach 100 Meter weg, ist der down, nee oder, Leute ich hab ein Problem, ich
hab ein Problem, mein Trapling Hook ist nicht da, ok, nice, wo, wo, wo ist der Dude der
den gekillt hat, oder ist er einfach runtergefallen, ok da unten geht einiges, ach hier, ok da
kommen einige, oh, oh, da unten gehts richtig ab, da unten gehts richtig ab, oh auf der
anderen Seite, alter unter mir man, und ich hab keine Muni mehr, fuck, ist hier Muni,
please, please Muni, nice Pog, Pog, Pog Moon, Pog Moon, Muni wieder leer, ok, er ist in
die Bobbes, alter diese Hit Detection man, alter da kommen 50 Gegner gerade an, was mach
ich denn, da ist Muni, da ist Muni, ich renn jetzt hier durch bis ich Muni hab, Muni, please,
please Frau Muni, Muni, hat ihr mal Muni, ja ok nice, nice, nice easy, easy, alter was
kommt von da unten man, wir müssen, wir müssen die Ecke halten, Leute wir müssen die Ecke
halten, der stirbt jetzt wenn er da raus geht, pass auf, oder nicht, vielleicht können wir
da durch, oh nee shit, ok, ok, pushen, pushen, Jungs pushen, pushen, oh, oh, oh, oh, das ist
eine schlechte Posi, können wir hier irgendwie uns raus, Achtung, six head play, man kann
hier nicht oben drauf, ok, doch nicht, nicht six header gewesen, nicht, nicht six headig
genug, nicht six headig genug, da drüben kommt gerade eine Rakete, wir können hier
nicht raus Leute, ich, ich verreck jetzt gleich, ok, nice, unsere Dudes sind schon am Start,
na gut, sag ich nichts, da, da rüber werden wir abgeschossen, da rüber sollten wir jetzt
glaube ich nicht, es sei denn man ist Sundance und kann rüber stülsen, so jetzt muss, mehr
kann er die Karte glaube ich nicht anders verwenden, also wo gehen wir hin, C, C1 sind
sie, ok auf gehts, C1, alter wie ich es hasse, dass das einfach verbugt ist zwischendurch
dieser grappling hook, der geht einfach manchmal nicht, oh da oben, da oben ist richtig was
los, ja also die Map ist wirklich nice, ich wurde gehackt, ist das grappling hook, Moment
in dem Moment wo das wusste ich gar nicht, in dem Moment wo man gehackt wird geht dann
das gadget aus, ist das, ist das wirklich so, das wäre ja fast wie in Overwatch, fuck,
es sind einfach zu viele, links, rechts, rechts, links, nice, so, aber solange wir C1 halten
sollte das gehen, wir müssten die Runde glaube ich eh ganz gut geben, alter wir dominaten
die richtig weg, guck mal hier 726 zu 144, nächste Runde wahrscheinlich genau umgedreht,
die kommen ja von hier, oder auch nicht, ich check den Flow nicht, von wo, ok, doch C1,
oder nicht, ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer wo hier was abgeht, da oben auf dem Dach ist
einer auf jeden Fall, oh oh, Haley, Haley, alter, WTF, einer und auf einmal sind es 5,
Captain Peng ich lade dich ein, jawoll, klar, nach der Runde, nach der Runde lade ich dich
ein und wir gucken Season Pass, da können wir ein bisschen capen, ok, nope, no pass,
erinnert mich mal nach der Runde 3, ich die Captain Poggers einlade, guck mal die Gegner
haben schon keinen Bock mehr, ich kann jetzt einfach, ich renne jetzt hier einfach ein
bisschen im Kreis bis die Runde vorbei ist, so Runde vorbei, ok, Captain Poggers auf geht's,
aber der sozusagen, C1, Commander Pogger ist
ok, Mas frequent, C1, C1, das ist ok, nein, das ist ok doch, Phall weak Cleft, ja und
Cop, ok, und der
hofft dem Backirm, das war das, wie er das war, die hat mich nicht be
erартet und den
Zeitraup das warmonster kann ne criticsuffe hier, was meinen die?
D natuurlijk ngườien sich, ich mein, auf die
ich will sehen
sidearm kills
ich hab die meisten kills im team ordentlich gebashed
alles klar
wo ist der captain poggers
den muss ich einladen
noch jemand
guck mal hier
massive emblem
das nehm ich
das sieht tatsächlich ganz nice aus
ich drücke übrigens gerade rechts
ah jetzt hab ich equipped
continue
alles klar
social, pc
ja
poggers
wie der cha aussieht
ich hab halt überhaupt keine
skins
also am liebsten einen den ich noch
voltic
wie heißt du
einfach voltic auf
er
sollst du mitmachen
du hast wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal gesehen
wie edit man hier eigentlich leute
search for friends
voltic
volt
foric
nee
das war bestimmt kleinschreibst du
case sensitive
nice, das ist schon gleich gewonnen
mit dem profile pick
so
dann nehmen wir mal an
der opa pajama hat es richtig
der spielt einfach battle field 4
ach du hast das game nicht
ja das hast du richtig gemacht
ist da sonst noch jemand
ok
voltic
ja
also
alles klar
play
ach leute season pass guckt euch das mal an
ja
guckt euch das mal an
es gibt
ah lass mich das
man kann doch nicht mal maus scrollen
also guckt euch das an ihr könnt euch angucken
dass es im prinzip nichts gibt
irgendwie sondern nicht
es gibt irgendwelche
ja die camo die brauche ich unbedingt
ja zu langsam
aber nicht dass es
eigentlich spannend wäre
es wäre cool könnte man das
in rush spielen allerdings bin ich
völlig sicher ob die map in rush funktioniert
ja ich weiß auch nicht was mir los ist ich dachte
was ich hab heute mittag gespielt
und ich
hab auch was aufgenommen
zu und ich dachte mir komm wenn es schon
installiert hast schreibst du das ganze nochmal
vielleicht entdecken wir
noch irgendwelche neuen sachen und
ja
und ich installiers wahrscheinlich
also ich hab es nicht lange installiert
wie findest du es bis jetzt
ganz ehrlich es hat sich ja nichts
getan an dem game das einzige
nennenswerte was es gibt ist eine
neue map und das war's
den specialist ist nicht der rede wert
ne ich bin schlechter heli mensch
und die waffen ist
die as wallock wir können eigentlich
mal anfangen die neuen waffen
zu anlocken
oder auch nicht
so jetzt
zeig ich euch wie man
einen guten runden start macht
also man wartet bis man
eingeflogen wurde
warum auch immer es diese
einpflege animation überhaupt gibt
und jetzt pass mal auf jetzt
kommt der pock runden start man geht hier
hin und sagt redeploy
und dann
dreht man
däumchen
bis die leute dort sind wo man
wirklich ins game rein will
zigziger
jetzt guckt man sich das alles
an und dann
wartet man bis es eingenommen ist
oh der ist nice hier der ist
so und jetzt kann man da
rein so und jetzt gehts weiter
first frag
first frag who cares
who cares first frag
so
wir machen jetzt hier flug action
über die
seite
und
und weil das c1
ist ohne scheiß leute c1 ist mit
abstand die wichtigste
da kommt was runter gedroppt
nice
schön vom heli geballert da oben
kommt was
was
fack
die habe ich schlecht durch die schalbe
gesehen
egal release hier rettet mich keiner
würde mich zumindest
wundern
so gehen wir mal in mein
teamkollegen rein
der ist es
da müssen wir hin
so
ich glaube wir haben es
what the fack heli mensch
hau ab
so und jetzt
hast du halt das problem
ey man lass mich in ruhe
jetzt hast du halt das problem
man muss irgendwie
aaah
das mal geht es mal geht es nicht
es ist pain pain
champ
dieses klippen gameplay mal hängst
mal kannst du hin und mal mich
ganz schlimm
wo sind denn die gegner
die eins kriegen die gerade
wieder richtig auf den sack kann das sein
ja gut
auf gehts
volle pulle
der erwartet mich jetzt ja dass ich hier
rüber rum gehe
wow
da stehen einfach 5 gegner drinne
ähm vielleicht
haben wir glück es sind ja immerhin einige
dudes oh
voltic bester retts
bester rettser
man
ich bin mir
unschlüssig ob ich hier
location oh
hallo
kannst du dich mal please heilen geht das
pepega hip spray
gesprüht und gebetet
fuck hätte ich den noch erwischt
nein hier ist kein retts mehr möglich ihr seht nur noch gegner
massive retts war das eben richtig
mvp res
machen die denn hier
ja kurz
ja der warlock ist aber nicht so wild
der warlock ist von der
von dem koreanischen operator
den spielt keiner also das ding ist
wirklich müll
aber ja es gibt einen kurzen wallhack gebraucht
hat es keiner gefragt
hat auch keiner danach
also eigentlich
im prinzip wie so ziemlich
90 prozent
wow da ist bodice
bodice
besser gesagt bodice
maschinengewehr
ja
Leute wir sind 36
da geht noch was
heli sind richtig gut in dem spiel
so jetzt aber
jetzt machen wir den
ah klippen please
captain poggers
achtung
die klippen machen mich fertig
mag jeder's mag jeder's net
ok noch mal
noch ein versuch
ah jetzt gehts
ok
jetzt ist der x mal da
what the
ok
jetzt
zählt
wow
alter
das sind 500 gegner mann
oh Gott
dieses movement mann
ach Gott
dieses movement es macht mich so
fertig wenn das mal funktioniert
und mal nicht unglaublich
das war übrigens die neue specialist
rakete
wer durchs feld
dafür spiel ich den ja
ey von hinten
ok wir kommen nicht vorwärts
ah guck mal da unten ist einer reingestellt
ne gar nicht
der kommt da genauso wenig weiter wie ich
das war eine ziemlich blöde idee
da will ich eigentlich auch hin
ich will ehrlich gesagt da auf die
seite gucken ob das funktioniert
genau hier hin
und jetzt gucken ob ich irgendwie klippen
stills machen kann von oben
alter please
warum kann man manchmal hoch und manchmal nicht
das ist einfach
das ist un
ähm soll ich sagen
das ist weniger nachvollziehbar wie in battle field 3
wie in battle field 3
und das heißt schon was
jetzt bräuchten wir C5
C4 warum haben die das eigentlich C5
genannt ich mein das hat ja einen
sinn dass es C4 heißt C4 ist
ja irgendwie so chemisch die zusammensetzung
C5 ergibt wahrscheinlich überhaupt keinen
sinn das ist einfach C5
weil irgendjemand nicht
versteht warum C4 C4 heißt
ok die runde ist
relativ ausgeglicht aber wir sacken richtig
hart rein
letzte runde
ok
es gucken einfach zu viel in die richtung
ok so
haben wir irgendwas hier noch
nope keine chance ok wir müssen C1
rein spawnen dass wir irgendwie
eine chance haben den kram zu halten
wobei guck mal ich spone C1 und guck mal wo ich
rauskomme 130 meter von
C1 weg
aber wir kommen hinter den gegnern
raus das ist natürlich auch äußerst
äußerst nett
sehr nett danke
für den spawn easy
würde mich jetzt wahnsinnig freuen
wenn ich der gegner wäre
einfach mal
gesandwich die dudes
wegen den spawns wir sind einfach um die drumme rum
gespawned und haben sie gesandwiched
es ist ja nicht so als
wenn die gegner das schlecht gemacht
oder so
äh ja übrigens der scoreboard ist am start
sagen wir die haben den cooldown vom grappling hook
besser gemacht oder?
vielleicht ähm
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man mittlerweile wiederbelebt werden kann
wenn man in der wand steckt
am anfang ging das ja nicht
äh anscheinend
wahrscheinlich geht das immer noch nicht
ne das game taugt mittlerweile immer noch nicht
wie kommste drauf
nein nein das taugt immer noch nicht
achtung massive nade
ok die bounce nicht
ich hab gehofft die bounce oh nice
richtig richtig geil
einfach einfach einfach reingesprayed
klar
habt ihr den panzer gesehen?
dadurch dass du nicht mal
spawnen kannst hast ja keinen plan wo was abgeht
äh was war nochmal das spawnmenü
b?
öh öh öh öh
öh was lässt man denn jetzt hier am besten spawnen?
in hovercraft
ok vergesst es
hier kommen wir nicht lang
du kommste halt auch nicht rüber
jetzt ne
mit der wand
als sniper
ah nice guck mal
die leute sind drüben
oh massive
massive posi
poggers pos hier
poggers pos
gucken euch an so muss es machen
oh
da gucken einfach 20 leute in die
gleiche richtung heftig
rätts mich bloß nicht rätts mich bloß nicht
ok ok ich bin dead
ich bin dead
nein ich bin nicht dead
not dead
massive net
wie lange noch ne halbe stunde oder so dann ist vorbei
oh massive nein kein res ok
lass das lass das bleiben
aber wenigstens ist mein team nicht schlecht
lass immer
beruhigen
da wollen wir eher nicht hin
wobei da ist gar nicht schlecht die posi wenn der auch
immer noch da ist
das kann keiner main gamen
das game hat einfach kein content
du kannst es nicht main gamen
ach wie schön
das sind 64 spielerkäber
komm wir sind jetzt mal in jolo
modus wir gehen jetzt hier in das ding rein
und wo sind wir
komplett über die gegner
wir choppen jetzt einfach hier
ok nice
da schießt gleich
irgendwas auf mich
ich hab keine ahnung was
da hinten rennt irgendwas ich hab's gesehen
oh da ist ein hedel
nice nice nice
oh
keine chance
ja
was
hat jemand eine idee wie
ich unbegrenzt hinterher in meine neue
wohnung komme was was meinst du mit
unbegrenzt
wenn die telekom rumspackt
oder vorn falls es was gibt
wo sind wir
ach gott wie dieses hümpeln manchmal
nicht funktioniert alter
ich bleib jetzt hier einfach stehen
da gehts da vielleicht
hey
ach mensch
ey hallo
wo sind wir eigentlich blöde frage
wo sind wir eigentlich
irgendwo hinter d oder so
bergziehen gameplay
ey das könnte so schön ich kann übrigens nichts machen
der rutscht gerade
also ich weiß nicht
keine ahnung pepega kram
probier was mal hier durch
das ist der verbuggte tunnel guck mal da hinten
super super mega hdr
ich zeig euch das mal
da buggt das game so rum dass es den kompletten
bildschirm für irgendwie über
1-2 minuten kaputt geht
also ich mein ist klar dass es so hell ist
im tunnel logisch
obvios und dass diese steine
hier so leuchten ist auch klar
so hin ist ein fahrstuhl und das letzte mal
wo ich mit dem fahrstuhl gefahren bin
war danach mein komplettes game für ne minute kaputt
alter sind wir schlecht die runde
so hier gehts auf gleich
irgendwann
gehts hier auf
ey nein jetzt ist es nicht verbuggt
das letzte mal ging die brightness
immer weiter hoch
da kommt ein auto
da machst du halt nichts
ok easy
wir gehen jetzt einfach mal bei f und campen uns da rein
falls wir den weg schaffen
dann mal da oben
tropfen schon 5
das sind vögel
das ist die einzige
die einzige sache die es auf den maps gibt
ab und zu mal ein vogel
was ist das layout von den dingern
ok
da vielleicht
kann man da rein
ich will da rein
hallo
hey
uns
das hat keiner
bock zu defend
alles klar
man kann rauf
ich kenne die dinger
die haben ja die gleichen dinger auch auf
den anderen maps frag mich jetzt nicht
ich weiß die haben nicht mehr
ok wir capturen den einfach mal
alles weg
also wir haben die runde anscheinend richtig heftig dominatet
muss ich nicht
sollen wir aber recht sein
unser team hat gerockt das ist die hauptsache
oh da kommt ein pence
der pence man ist am start
oh
nicht schlecht
wenn ich dich versuche zu holen
nope keine chance
der shootet mir in the bobs
die maps sieht unfertig aus
das ist wie alle outdoor battlefield
2042 maps
die sehen alle unfertig aus draußen
vor allem draußen
weil da fällt dir halt auf dass nichts da ist
wohlgemerkt ich spiele jetzt auch nicht auf ultra high details
oder so aber trotzdem
die maps sollten zumindest ein bisschen
näher machen als in battlefield 4
ich soll euch mal aufhören wie schön
die battlefield 1 und
5 maps waren
das ist der neue
stelz heli ist das
wo geht hier eigentlich was
keine ahnung
wir haben eh gewonnen jetzt easy
easy win easy
patchnotes gucken wir uns nicht an
so sehr interessiert es mich jetzt auch nicht
es ist besser als alle anderen
battlefield 2042
jeez genau
es ist besser als alle anderen
battlefield 2042 maps
das ist übrigens der neue specialist
die hat so nen
at4 quasi
falls ihr noch jemand kennt
ja lange spiele ich das auch nicht
ich dachte mir bevor ich
es wieder aninstalle wir können
noch wir können noch mal ne runde
uns das angucken
sag mal leute im menü ruckelts immer
ein bisschen in game wenn ich spiele
ruckelts dann nicht
das ist irgendwie menü ist
kaputt
die sache ist halt die
dass diese eine map
selbst wenn die gut
ist halt nicht
mal ansatzweise am game im
gesamten was macht
also was ändert
du hast quasi neun maps musst euch mal
vorstellen neun
glaub schon oder
in dem dreh auf jeden fall bin mir nicht ganz
sicher du hast neun maps
du hast eigentlich
nichts an irgendwie großartig im content du hast
kein server browser du hast keine playlist
keine spieleauswahl
gescheit du kannst dann nicht mal das spielen
also wenn dir das game keinen bock macht
bis auf sagen wir mal
eins zwei sachen du kannst ja noch nicht mal
sagen ich spiele diese eins zwei
sachen dann eben hauptsächlich
gibt's einfach nicht
das game ist dead das wird übrigens auch mal
ein videotitel wahrscheinlich für morgen
gute map für totes game oder
irgendwie sowas
oder chat preisfrage
wer hat
gute video ideen video titel
also ich hab schon heute gecaptured
ich hab heute auch schon was aufgenommen
zum season
update
also ich werde es wahrscheinlich sowas
in der richtung nennen wie gute map für totes game
irgendwie zu
zu wenig zu spät
irgendwie sowas man braucht hier immer zwei sachen
man braucht den five header
titel und den
thumbnail text
besser spät als nie
wäre auch ein ganz guter titel so
aber das trifft es ja nicht so ganz
alles neu ne sowas mache ich nicht
das sollte glaube ich jeder gecheckt haben dass das
vorbei ist mit dem game
cringe
warum
irgendjemand bei dice muss aktiv
da gesessen haben und sich gedacht haben
das ist eine gute ideen das
jetzt sagen zu lassen
was
schickt den ivan
heim hat er gerade gesagt
das passt ja gar nicht darauf habt ihr nicht gewartet das ist gar nicht schlecht das ist
gar kein schlechter titel darauf habt ihr nicht gewartet das ist gar nicht schlecht das ist
trotzdem so interessant dass die leute sagen dann klicke ich da mal drauf
diese dinger sind übrigens reine verzierung diese ospreys die da am anfang rumfliegen
aber kann man die dauerfeuer machen oder zu über jetzt näher an der rechts unten in der
eckel sieht man das die heat jetzt wird der heli wird geswiffer skoppt leute hacker mann hacker
wo ist er denn überhaupt irgendwo da alter wort da ja ist ja gut
ruckel ruckel da ist er ich kann nicht so hoch gucken ich kann nicht so hoch zielen
keine chance ich komme nicht höher wo überdüsen wir ob wir machen den six hat play wir wollten
alles capturen davon ist was nice nice 22 so viel was das ist
wellfield 22 42 dort die eins kommt die wir gehen die eins volle pulle die eins da ist
voll as fuck hallo wo sind wir überhaupt wo sind wir denn überhaupt gesporned
capturet das noch ist capturen auch links links wieder sich dauernd kackel alter hyper kackel
geht kackel eigentlich jetzt ich habe es aktiviert kackel geht nice die eins kommen jetzt aber
hier geben wo sind wir wieder
hier ist wieder der klatsch guck mal hier ist wieder der klatsch geklatschte sonnenlicht
es aber hier sollte man die sonne durchscheinen oder das ist irgendwie ziemlich ziemlich
broken
nein das ist battlefield 22 42 das ist das was letztes jahr raus kamen wo sie gesagt
haben das wird der nächste neue service game hit und dann gab es kein service mehr für
das game das was sie unter service verstehen da unten war ich noch nie ich sehe auch nicht
den sinn da hinzugehen love letter to the fans genau ist was auf dem dach
ist boris boris
nix da lasse ich mir auch gefallen ist ok da können wir nicht hin da habe ich keinen
bock rüber zu gehen leute wo ist denn hier was das hatte überhaupt kein flow das ganze
zeug alter ok 2 komm wir sind wir sind mal so frei wir sind mal so frei und gehen jetzt
3 stunden
das ist ein ranger ich dachte es ist ein gegner das erkennt man natürlich bei dem game auch
wieder nicht map scheint einseitig zu sein nee also ich habe auch schon oft genug auf
den sack gekriegt
nice ein nicer spawn sehr gut spawn ist immer perfekt wenn gleich alles um dich drumherum
explodiert
ok das ding ist halt nicht auf range ausgelegt aber es geht
heli weg weg weg ins bein also ihr habt gesehen bein ist äußerst verwundbare stelle die kommen
noch hier rein jetzt oder hier sind schon wieder auf dem dach
sehr gut mitten in die arme rein gelassert da oben auf dem dach ist ganz schön action
das sind bestimmt 15 leute gerade jetzt was los in combat spams spams spams spams spams
map nicht mehr in combat ok ich hole dich was zum was ist das der heli
ach das ist boris achtung massive flank boris ok die haben sich da ziemlich verkempt oben
auf dem dach
dann müssen wir jetzt 6 hat play machen ja gut 6 hat play gemacht und alles weg das
ganze kackel ja das kann man immer retten by the way was genau hat mich da gerade von
hinten gekillt da war nix irgendwas von da oben vielleicht ok 5 hat play 5 hat play
hallo hallo please ente haken kommen wir kommen wir ready
das kopfschmerz ach wenn ich das mit 37 aushalte dann geht das schon also ich bin mir gerade
echt unschlüssig wo man lang rennen soll ok da unten geht wieder was
da was
ist klar dachte ich man kann kreppeln aber gibt es nicht kackel also eigentlich wollte
ich eh drücken und dann den fallschirm aber das hat nicht funktioniert
massiv da fallen sie alle rum
kommen 30 milliaren gegners und da oben mal da hat er gerade gesagt kackel one has been
secured habt ihr das auch gehört kackel one ich hab das genau gehört
nein nein nein heli ok ich sollte nicht mehr revealed sein
aber das heli ist schlecht für mich ganz schlecht wo ist denn hier überhaupt was da
ist gar nichts mehr hier über mir oder wo
ich hab keine ahnung wo hier was abgeht mein problem ist ich komm nicht mehr weg
da oben sind sie ja ich seh dich ich seh dich ne ne ne kollege
kackel one ne das funktioniert so nicht das ist das das ist nicht für kreppling hook
die du ins ausgelegt hier ja klar man wupp wupp was war gestern los sagst du gestern
schmoller ja ne die game show wollte ich nicht mit dem chat angucken ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich hab mir wieder die xbox game show noch sonst was angeguckt ich muss mir noch
ein paar zusammenfassungen angucken aber es ist so langweilig in den letzten jahren alles
ich bin null konzentrate vielleicht ist gleich gleich der rage quit angesagt bzw. kein bock
mal quitt erst zwei runden voll konzentratet rein und jetzt halt residenz lieber war alles
müll bis auf starfield ok schnell schnell schnell jawoll hat noch geklappt so jetzt
gehen wir da rein ok wenn wir glück haben wenn wir glück haben können wir da jetzt
den massif flank machen ja wenn das wenn das wenn es halt mit diesen komischen what
ok ja hier ist gut hier ist gut hier will ich bleiben hier ist perfekt jetzt massiv
stehen halt 20 gegner war irgendwas war irgendwas spannendes dabei irgendwas was euch interessiert
hat bei diesen ganzen xbox game show es war jeder hat jeder hat geschaut wie er macht
eigene show keine ahnung es ist halt alles übelst langweilig das ist halt so viel heiße
luft um um nix das ist dass ich guck der grund warum ich das nicht mal angucke ist weil die
können alle nix mehr normal präsentieren anstatt einfach mal zu sagen anstatt anstatt
einfach mal zu sagen wir machen den kram halt nur 20 minuten lang und dafür füllen
wir den mit interessanten sachen machen die das immer eine stunde und labern sich dann
den den den mundfusselig das ist all new noch nie da gewesen und und super thrilled
und und hyped sind zu announced und das ist alles so so ein heißes geluft immer ja fabriziert
deswegen ich kann mir das nicht mal angucken was auch immer haben sie weiß ich nicht ob
sie sich zurück gehalten haben ich gucke ja nicht mehr massif gameplay ich weiß ich
halte glaube ich nicht lang durch dem los oder steht ein panzer unten einfach das ist
ziemlich schlecht für mich jetzt das ist einfach ein panzer das ist ziemlich blöd
was auf die kommen doch hier lang irgendwo herz kacke
kann man die nicht kühlen da drinnen oder was
pass auf pass auf pass auf pass auf dort der massiv massiv feife da massiv feife da
das sind doch gar keine mg ok ok einstein
schon wieder alles vorbei
so wo sind sie die kleinen kackels auf geht's vielleicht sind auch schon ausgewachsene
kacke dabelius
ich glaube hier ist weg oder was nächstes mal da hier ist noch was
achtung blub da kommt was
hier checkst du überhaupt nicht wo was abgeht das auto gesehen was war mit dem auto grad
los was war mit dem auto los das ist einfach komplett über die map gekickt die map besteht
im prinzip aus zwei tolle
im prinzip
ja ich habe geprägt die hand zum klub wo kam jetzt hier die letzten die letzten zwei
schuss hätte ich nicht ppegern dürfen
massiv cleanup ja warum ist die pistole eigentlich nicht immer auf auto gestellt
du kommst in diesem game nirgends wo raus achtung der pusht gleich
ok in cs hätten die nicht durchgepusht
so das ist halt das geile dann hast du irgendwelche selbsternannten heli pros die dann auch noch
rum heulen wenn die leute die runter geiern
was haben wir da ist es die anti er ich weiß noch nicht mal was mich gekillt hat gerade
die heli und jetpost gab es ja aber die maps war nicht so groß offen und weitläufig und
die infanterie dinger waren meistens soweit geschützt wenn du infanterie gespielt hast
dass du nicht permanent
und es war nicht umsonst so dass die infanterie lasting maps die beliebtesten waren was willst
du da machen wenn du da rein rennst bist du halt direkt kackel bist du dann
der tue oh hier ist was los ist richtig was los eigentlich muss man jetzt sinnlos abkampen
bis da einer den kopf raus steckt was anderes kannst du halt machen
kacke pence boris geschützt ok jolo einfach mal raus gespringen guck mal da stehen 40
spieler hier oben gerade so gibt es was anderes was wir hier machen können wir können immer
das gleiche spielen was haben wir hier und den freck brauchen wir mit der nicht die hat
ihre eigenen granaten proximity sensor ist nicht da wollte ich nicht rein ich wollte
bei meinen leuten spawn na gut da können wir jetzt immerhin wie ging das noch mal ich
weiß ich weiß nicht mehr wie man den shit fliegt leute ich bin outdated overrated schiebade
einfach in boden crash easy ist das standardmäßig die splittergranate
ein splittergranate ist halt schon poc hier
was ist hier los das ist halt so battlefield shit allerdings
war es halt in alten teilen cool du konntest noch irgendwie halbwegs kontrollieren
kackel es handelt sich übrigens also ich finde ganz ehrlich mit mit webster ist das
ding ist einfach op krasses movement ziemlich starke fähigkeiten aber ist jetzt nicht so
als würde es in dem game irgendwie großartig jucken ja was op ist und was nicht op ist
zbons approval bestquetter ja ich habe die
wie chain0 mit großen
ahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha
hahallala
A1, eins könnte man noch machen, zwei sidearm kills, ja das war sicherlich das wichtigste
was ich die Runde gemacht habe, zwei sidearm kills, denke das ist tatsächlich sehr, muss
man hervorheben.
Keckl, das ist die Kombination aus Keck W und Lull, ist mir gerade eingefallen, irgendwie
spontan am Anfang des Streams und dann habe ich nachgeguckt und dann habe ich festgestellt
dass es Keckl auch tatsächlich als Emotion gibt.
Lull W Keck W ja, ist immer noch so, ist true, true, okay eine Runde spiele ich noch,
das reicht dann ist 21.30 Uhr oder so, vielleicht gucken wir uns dann noch, ich muss mal kurz
im Handy gucken, ich habe extra Playlist auf dem Handy, wo ich interessante Videos speichere
drin, die man sich vielleicht mal zusammen angucken könnte, aber ich glaube da ist nix
spannendes drinne, oder wollt ihr gucken, der Spessart im Fokus, Bilder einer Landschaft,
nee das wollt ihr wahrscheinlich nicht gucken oder, 1 Stunde 2.0, das habe ich in meiner
YouTube Playlist drin, ich finde sowas sehr beruhigend immer, das ist Boomer Entertainment,
ich weiß aber, zum Pennen sind so Dokus immer wunderbar, da kann man super bei einschlafen.
Essen schönste Wanderwege ist auch sowas, da kann man wunderbar bei Pennen, dann hätte
ich noch ein Video zu bieten, The Beauty of Unix Porn, wer das nicht kennt, Unix Porn
ist ein Subreddit, wo die Leute ihre gepimpten Desktops zeigen, eigentlich sind es hauptsächlich
irgendwelche Tiling Window Manager zum größten Teil, E3 W genau Neo Fetch fertig, da gehst
du vielleicht bald hin, ich bin regelmäßig wandern im Spessart, einfach weil es recht
nahe ist, näher als Taunus bei mir, zumindest die Spessart Ausläufer, Spessart, Leute kann
das sein, dass wir immer nur gespornet sind bisher auf einer Seite, ah ok, wir spawnen
tatsächlich mal auf der anderen Seite, Kekl, ah ja, es gibt ziemlich viele so Mountainbike
Trails und sowas da, das habe ich schon öfters gesehen, bin auch schon einmal fast bei Mountainbiker
zusammengestoßen, der hat nicht richtig geguckt und ich auch nicht, und es ist nicht so als
wäre ich da auf irgendeiner Strecke für die Mountainbiker gelaufen, sondern die Strecke
für die Mountainbiker kommt aus dem Wald, geht kurz auf normalen Laufweg und geht dann
auf der anderen Seite weiter, nur nach einem kleinen paar Meter auf dem Gehweg, also auf
dem normalen Wanderweg, und geht dann weiter und die sind dann voll drübergeheizt, er
hat mich fast erwischt, da habe ich MonkaS gesagt, er hat MonkaS, das war knapp, ja und
die Mountainbiker haben mich angeguckt und haben gesagt MonakS, ja ganz bestimmt, true
real story Leute, darf ich, darf ich, ah hey, oh, oh, ich habe vergessen, dass ich, ich
dachte ich bin Webster, bin ich nicht, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, ok hier kommt jetzt
ganz viel, oder auch nicht, wo sind denn die alle, da, schon der nächste, der nächste
Kekler, Kekler und Koch, oh Gott, ich weiß, ich muss aufhören Leute, too far, oh Gott,
ja in dem Spiel gibt es ja keine Waffenhersteller in dem, oh schnell, schnell, schnell rein,
Wurzeln, Alter da habe ich doch im Leben nicht spawnen gedrückt, ich habe auf B spawnen
gedrückt, wo spawn ich irgendwo im Tunnel, sonst wo, ausgekekelt hier, Outplayed, der
Puma kann es noch, Leute, ich höre hier was
ok, ich verteidige die Server, ja
aber man hört die Gegner halt mal nicht richtig, ja so mache ich das ja auch sonst in meinem
rechten Zentrum, wisst ihr, deswegen war ich beim Provider früher, die wussten schon,
was da abgeht, das sind die Turnschuheatmens, wisst ihr,
aber diese Granate,
was ist hier, oh kann man hier starten, nein hier kann man nicht launchen, ich dachte ich
kann hier rüberfliegen mit dem Wingsuit, aber das war nicht hoch genug, oh, Gachi
Bus Time, Leute, Gachi Bus, ok, alles klar, Gachi Bus Time, Achtung, von hinten, in the
Bobs hier, sind die alle down oder was, sind die alle weg, alle down, passt es nicht, du
schaffst es nicht, null, sei mal, bin ich jetzt einmal im Kreis gelaufen, das war wirklich
einfach, hier, schön in deinem Poker kämpfen, alles klar, habt ihr den gesehen, ich habe
keine Ahnung, Boomer Augen, eindeutig, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam,
Spam, ja, lass mich rein, was ist denn hier an der Ecke los, was ist hier an der Ecke,
Okay, hier kannst du doch nichts machen.
Ähm...
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich rumfliege, Leute.
Ich, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich, ich will eigentlich wieder zurück.
Was ist denn das?
Ist der Panzer noch da?
Okay, der Panzer war...
Der Panzer weiß nicht so genau, was er da treibt.
Wie kommt man hier jetzt wieder, Nuff?
Erstmal, erstmal hier unten ins, ins, da, in das Ding, in die Röhre campen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das Ding nennen soll.
Umgekippter Container oder so?
Container.
Sektor secured.
Kann man hier vorn launchen?
Nee.
Ist hier was?
Da schießt irgendwas hin!
Ich hab keinen Schimmer.
Probier das jetzt einfach mal aus, ich geh da jetzt hin.
Da war was!
Tatsächlich.
Ey, wir sind ganz schön am Arsch der Welt.
Kann man von hier starten?
Okay, das bringt nix.
Okay, drei Stunden rennen.
Easy.
Kommt, kommt man hier hoch?
Kann man hier? Aha.
Das ist halt viel zu, ist halt viel zu langsam.
Wenn ich jetzt noch wüsste, wie man Sand ins Zeug fliegt, noch kann ich das nicht.
Man konnte mit dem Ding nämlich nahezu und endlich...
Guck mal, was für eine Geschwindigkeit bei diesen Map Größen, Alter.
Das ist 2042, bis dahin könnten die doch ein bisschen was schnelleres entdeckt haben.
Übrigens überlebt man immer. Easy.
Easy. Easy überleben hier.
So immer und der Körper...
Also immer mit dem Körper...
Direkt mit dem Körper gegen den Felsen, das ist...
kein Ding.
Keinefin im Pronounce.
Wo sind die eigentlich gerade?
Wo sind die eigentlich gerade? Ach, hier, an der Seite!
Ach, hier, an der Seite! Kommen sie grad rein.
Oder?
Nein.
Wo sind die denn alle?
Von der anderen Seite?
Mache ich auch immer 3-Head?
Ja.
Nur so wird man ein richtiger 3-Head.
Aha, so sieht es also aus.
Nicht reinkommen Leute.
Okay, Motion Sensor.
Hier geht was.
So, wo geht wieder was?
Ja, geht nichts.
D, D könnten wir gehen.
Aber da kommen wir wahrscheinlich nicht rüber.
Nix da?
Okay, Achtung.
Okay, das war blöd.
Ich weiß nicht mehr wie dieses Ding fliegt.
Ich wollte eigentlich da reinfliegen, aber okay.
Ich habe übrigens einfach nur sinnlos gesprayt.
Ich habe 3-4 Gegner gesehen, ich wusste nicht, wo ich draufschießen soll.
Das war sehr optimistisch, ja.
Guck mal da.
Nochmal, wir sind nochmal optimistisch.
Okay, das habe ich nicht mehr drauf.
Weiß ich, ob ich das jemals hatte.
Ah, das ist ein roter, das ist nur ein roter Ding.
So, so, rauf rauf rauf rauf, Sundance.
Mal kurz, mal kurz hier abcampen.
Und was ist in einer Sekunde?
Mich geht mit an gekackelt.
Oh man ey, ich muss mir das abgewöhnen, sonst fange ich mit so einem scheiß Wort an.
Das war früher mit dem Friseur, wo ich mit dem Friseur gespielt habe, so schlimm.
Wir hatten manchmal irgendwelche Wörter und wir haben die wochenlang, wochenlang immer
die gleichen Wörter uns alle 2 Sekunden, also das war, das Schlimme ist, wenn man sich
so was angewöhnt, man sagt es dann auch einfach random.
Einfach so, da Arsch.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, oh Poggers, Pograts, Pograts, ehm, ok, was auch immer, lag, I guess,
du sprichst in Emojis, also mir rutscht tatsächlich manchmal null, keck, weh, teilweise ist sogar
Gatschi Bass raus, stellt euch mal vor, es sagt jemand, real life Gatschi Bass, Alter.
Es hat zum Glück noch nie jemand gefragt, was ist denn das?
Die sind bloß schon gewöhnt, dass ich dummes Zeug von mir gebe, es hat mich noch nie einer
gefangen, Max erklär mal, was ist eigentlich Gatschi Bass?
Die Leute ignorieren das einfach, ah, da campt einer auf dem Dach, da kann ich jetzt nichts
dagegen machen, ey, es ist clusterfuck oder nix los, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich hin soll,
wir dominaten wieder die Runde, richtig heftig, wo ist denn was hier, ok, B1, B1 ist anscheinend
richtig Fogge, Fog G, ich renne einfach rein, es ist mir doch egal, da wird nicht in der
Ecke gesessen, da wird Bäm, da wird gepusht, guck mal, da oben, die Leute schon wieder
irgendwie mit 45, das sind irgendwelche Heli-Dudes, die den ganzen Tag nix anderes machen, oh,
da kann man rein spawnen, ah, Fifeheader, wow, Skatter, kann sich doch jemand an Hanzo
Skatter erinnern, ich weiß, kommt random, ist ein anderes Game, aber nur so, ist mir
nur gerade eingefallen, Skatter, guck mal, ich hab einen gescattert, guckt euch, Alter,
guckt euch diese clusterfuck an, guckt euch das an, wer hat sich bei Dice gedacht, oh,
das ist eine gute Idee, 128 Spieler, nice, nice, nice, gute Idee, gute Idee, 128 Spieler,
das ist geil, oh, was ist das, ah, das war der Wallhack, what, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, what the, 9 Euro Ticket ist das, genau, fremd vor der Hauptbahnhof, 9 Euro Ticket,
es ist wie Dema, wenn Peakey im Tunnel nur mit 128 Spieler, in Dema wenn Peakey schon
abfuckt, wenn 20 Leute da sind, oh, da, schnell, schnell, ah, Mist, in Combat, Spam, Spam,
Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam, Spam,
ah, es war kurz, Spam, Spam, oh, ne, ist dead, ok, hedi, Occupied, da rein vielleicht,
Occupied, nice, ok, yeah, it's easy, alter, was ein clusterfuck, man, das ist doch nicht
normal, so, Motion Sensor, Motion Sensor ist Pock, da sehen wir wenigstens was, Achtung
jetzt hier, der da, oh, nade, haha, ich hab immer noch zwei, guck mal, ich hab den Win
Kill gemacht, oh, Leute, reicht, genug, genug, hören wir so in den Cringe Outro Spruch
an, boah, 35, 1, ne, 35, nicht 1, WTF, Outstanding Performance, irgendein Heligeier Typ, Revive
is nice, das hab ich nix gegen, Spot Assist, oh, wer hat sich dieses Statistik ausgedacht,
seriously, was ist das, warum, wann kommt eigentlich Auge, ach, du meinst, die AUG,
die Dings hier, die Steyr AUG, oder so, ist das doch, oder, kann ich mich noch an CS dran
erinnern, Steyr AUG, ach, du bist ja auch der Austrian Farmer, jetzt versteh ich den
Zusammenhang, das ist ja österreichische Waffe, so, ich geh jetzt raus, Steyr gesprochen,
oh, wir haben einen Battle Pass Reward, Rip to Shreds, für die M5A3, zack, Rage Quit,
Bam, Desktop Capture, zack, Bam, ich hab ein bisschen hohe Bitrate, ich kann die Bitrate
leider nicht runterstellen, weil mein Decoder das nicht unterstützt, Moment, kann mein
Decoder das jetzt im laufenden Betrieb, das glaub ich aber nicht, oder, ist das jetzt
neu, können die das jetzt im laufenden Betrieb, ich nehm gleich mein WebAssembly Decoder,
der kann das bestimmt, wo, Stats, ne, ist ja immer noch 7,9, alles klar, so, mal kurz
die Kategorie ändern, just chatting, ne, 8K ist zu viel, wir haben Internet in Deutschland,
da können viele Leute nicht gucken, das muss ich aber auch nur machen, weil Battlefield
so pixelt, du siehst den OBS, du hast recht, ist es aber nicht, 0 Dropped Frames, normalerweise
stream ich immer mit 4,9, für ein bisschen Desktop Übertragungsstelle reicht das ja
eigentlich aus, so, gibt es irgendwelche spannenden Sachen, die wir noch gucken müssen hier,
Smart Home Automations, wir könnten uns den Diablo Rant von Maurice angucken, der sagt
bestimmt wohl überlegte Sachen, Web5 is coming, ist, Moment, Web3, war Web3 nicht diese Sachen,
wo die angefangen haben von wegen Krypto, Kryptogramm und sowas, und was ist jetzt,
ok, wir gucken uns das jetzt an, was ist Web5, und jetzt haben wir, und jetzt haben wir Web4
übersprungen, sind bei Web5, ich ändere jetzt mal den Titel, Titel, neuer Titel ist Kekke,
Leute, ich hab früher glaube ich auch manchmal so da gesessen, mittlerweile versuche ich
ein bisschen auf meine Haltung zu achten, und seitdem tut mir auch weniger der Rücken
weh, also man könnte fast vermuten, es hat was damit zu tun, was für ein Stuhl ich hab,
ich hab ein Sedus Mister 24, öfters gefragt, so ein Teil hier hab ich, Porkstuhl, weil
sehr stabil, ich glaube ich zugelassen bis 200 oder 250 Kilo, also selbst wenn ich mich
mit vollem Schmack es drauf klatsche, ist es auch nur kurzzeitig nicht schwerer, selbst
mal 2G nicht, richtig stabile Armlehnen, und Armlehnen links verstellbar, rechts verstellbar,
vorne hinten verstellbar, hoch und runter verstellbar, diagonal sogar, dementsprechend
halt auch, ansonsten kannst du auch so mehr oder weniger alles einstellen an diesem Stuhl,
wie hart der Rück, der Widerstand ist hier oben, du kannst es auch ganz feststellen,
die Sitzstelle, die Sitzfläche neigen und sonst, wie hart der Stuhl ist gut, den finde
ich richtig nice, ja ich hab einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch, den verwende ich aber viel seltener,
als ich mir das am Anfang gedacht habe, ja, also der Stuhl ist wirklich sehr, sehr nice,
ich kann den Stuhl allerdings nicht empfehlen, weil der Stuhl ist, achso den gibt es in
verschiedenen Dinger, ich hab die hier, ich kann den Stuhl nicht empfehlen, auch wenn
der nice ist, weil der Stuhl ist viel zu teuer, allerdings auf der anderen Seite, also guck
mal nur mal so, wovon wir hier reden, ja, Sedus, Sedus Mr24, wir reden von um, naja
das stimmt nicht ganz, also wir reden so von 1000 bis 1200 Euro für ein Stuhl, das hier
nicht, das ist, das ist pepega Preise, ja, und das ist natürlich nix, was man sich einfach
mal so just for fun irgendwie gönnt, aber wenn ihr jemand seid, der viel im Homeoffice
ist oder jemand, der einfach viel vom Rechner sitzt und vielleicht sogar auch damit Geld
verdient, dann sollte man sich das tatsächlich überlegen, ob es nicht sinnvoll ist einen
guten Stuhl zu kaufen, weil was habt ihr davon, wenn ihr permanent irgendwie Rückenschmerzen
oder Arschschmerzen oder sonstige Dinger habt, weil ihr zu lange vorm Rechner sitzt, ja,
das ist genauso, das ist genauso wie, ob man sich ein gutes Klo kaufen soll oder nicht,
ja Gaming Stühle sind Müll, das ist genauso, ob man sich ein gutes Klo kaufen soll, ja
soll man, es lohnt sich, so, five, which they're calling the decentralized web platform like
oder gutes Werkzeug, ja, you're serious, oh, das ist, Leute, forehead, forehead 3D ist
das, oh nee, okay, web 5 ist für mich schon mal durch, das ist irgendwas, was ich irgendwelche
Krypto Bros überlegt haben, uns einfach cool genannt haben, oh, juck mich, alles Krypto
Kram geht mir, geht mir auf den Sack, alles braucht Blockchain, wichtiger noch AI muss
auch noch sein, Leute, ich hab heute, ich war ja heute nicht arbeiten, wisst ihr ja,
ich hab ja, Montag ist immer frei, ich hab heute aber doch mal just for fun in die Mails
geguckt, refreshed und da hab ich irgendwie ein Ticket Eintrag bekommen und da stand
dann drinnen, Ed Max, bitte das Ticket auf hochpriorisieren und danach eine Minute später
bitte das Ticket auf sehr hochpriorisieren, ich hab das jetzt ignoriert, ich mein, ich
bin heute nicht da, vor allem, als ändert sich was da dran, das ist ein Ticket, was
ich mir genommen hab, weil derjenige, der sich eigentlich drum kümmert, jetzt krank
ist noch bis nächste Woche, ich hab mir das letzte Woche genommen in der Hoffnung, vielleicht
kann ich mal ein bisschen gucken, aber ich hab davon überhaupt keinen Plan, als würde
sich irgendwas ändern, wisst ihr, als habt ihr auf einmal Ahnung von einem Thema, nur
weil jemand gesagt hatte, ehm, priorisieren jetzt auf hoch, mein, wisst ihr, das ist
so, ah fuck, ich weiß nicht wie das geht, ich weiß nicht wie das geht und dann schreibt
einer, priorisieren auf hoch und ich sag, ah, jetzt weiß ich, ist alles klar, ich fang
an, was ist denn Spaß denn, ihr habt doch nach wie vor keine Ahnung, was die eigentlich
genau wollen, ich schreib einfach nur CackW in das Kommentarfeld rein, CackYou schreib
ich rein, weil er will ja was, nicht ich, CackYou, CackYou, das sagen wir wahrscheinlich
als Emote, CackYou haben wir auch, also ich hab bestimmt schon Comments auf der Arbeit
gemacht, die das drinne haben, also ich geh davon aus, ich hab bestimmt schon mal Twitch
comitted, magst du Australien, da gibt es mir zu viele Viecher, die mich umbringen,
ist ja egal, was du da hast, es bringt dich ja mehr oder weniger alles um, von Spinnen
bis Schlangen bis Insekten bis Krokodil, die haben ja alles, Skopio, nee, was das Skopio
haben, weiß ich gar nicht, wahrscheinlich, die haben alles, aus diesem Grund, also ich
hab mir schon sehr viele Drohnenaufnahmen und Landschaftssachen von Australien angeguckt,
da gibt es wirklich super Sachen, die man theoretisch eigentlich mal gesehen haben sollte,
aber ich glaub mich ziehts da nicht so hin, gibt es ein CackW, was wir noch nicht haben,
weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich haben wir das meiste CackFamilien treffen, oh Chico muss
wieder eingeplendet werden, Sekunde, Chico ist wieder da, so, gehackt, ich hacke einen
Online Shop, ok das ist G-Bait, weil ansonsten wäre das Video weg, könnt ihr euch noch an
dieses Video erinnern, wo sie McDonalds oder was es war angeblich gehackt haben, wo dann
irgendwelche Leute waren, die Gutscheine generiert haben und McDonalds dann so gesagt hat, ja
bin interessiert, und wo dieser Beitrag das getan hat, als sind es die mega krassesten
Hacker-Mans aller Zeiten, oder die Leute, die, ha ha, kennt ihr das noch, Moment Leute,
Ferrando, ja, geh mal nach Hanau, keine Ahnung, kennt ihr noch, kennt ihr noch dieses Video,
ja nicht, Slogan, Monka leck, feels leck man, naja, zumindest da gab es ein Video, wo die
Leute den Preis hier editiert haben, so im Browser-Menü, und der Web-Shop hat es gefressen,
und da haben sie auch getan, als wären es die krassen Snacker vor dem Hirn, ey, diese
Video-Empfehlung immer, meine Güte, Boomer, was haben wir denn noch zu gucken, komm wir
gucken uns jetzt mal, Diablo, Diablo, Diablo, das heißt nicht Diabolo, Alter, das heißt
Brant an, zeig mal her, die Sachen sind meistens immer überlegt, und warum ich die Sachen
von Maurice gerne gucke, der sieht die Dinge, ich meine das wieder so ist ja, der sieht
die Sachen oftmals ähnlich, wie ich sie auch sehe, das mag ich, man guckt sich ja gerne
Sachen an, die, ja, gleichgesinnt sind, und nur mit dem Unterschied, bei dem merkst du,
ja, macht sich Gedanken vorher, drei, vier Tage, was er sagt in einem Video, und das
schaut, ja, also das ist immer relativ, hat meistens Hand und Fuß, schon gesehen, dass
die Lugstashchaps ein neues Video über Smart Home gemacht hat, mehr oder weniger, ne, aber
ist wahrscheinlich nicht sonderlich spannend, Vampire Survivors gespielt, ist das dieses
Pixel Game, mit diesem, dieses, dieser Horde-Modus Pixel Game, wo man auflevelt und irgendwie
Items einsammelt, ich weiß nicht, wie diese Genreart heißt, das war mal vor drei, vier
Wochen voll angesagt auf Twitch, so, Maurice, schieß los, ich war dort, Gandalf, ich war
dort vor drei, äh, vor vier Jahren, ich war dort, als die Stärke von Blizzard versagte,
alles klar, da ist er, sie leise, oder, Techno, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
Techno.
Und das will ich mir in diesem Video mal näher anschauen.
Seriously, Manscaped. Erstmal Intimrasur durchgeführt.
Erlebt in diesem
Star ein
AK gemacht und ihrem Fazit kann ich mich vollumfänglich anschließen.
Das bringt es so gut auf den Punkt, dass ich sie einfach nochmal zitiere.
Diablo Immortal ist ein durchaus spaßiger Dungeon-Crawler,
dem aber das Herz und die Seele von Diablo fehlen.
Allerdings konnten wir zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht das volle Ausmaß der K2Win-Mechaniken abschätzen.
Tja, das konnte ja im Vorfeld kaum jemand.
Die haben ja auch gar nicht gesagt, was Sache ist.
Die haben so Sachen erzählt im Vorfeld.
Ja, du kannst dir garantiert nie Items kaufen und jetzt sagen sie,
ja wieso? Du kannst ja auch keine Items kaufen.
Du kannst dir aber Gems kaufen.
Das ist ja was ganz was anderes.
Version, oh Wunder, noch Teile des Shops deaktiviert waren.
Deswegen haben wir ganz bewusst gewartet, bis wir das Ding in seiner Gänze erfassen können.
Und das ist jetzt soweit.
Also, schnallt euch an.
Das wird eine schöne Fahrt.
Wild sagt Maurice nicht.
Diablo Immortal setzt bei der Charaktergestaltung sehr stark auf die legendären Edelsteine.
Einen davon können wir in jedes unserer sechs Kernartikel...
Übrigens, wisst ihr was witzig ist?
Was auch bei vielen Leuten, die bei mir den Video in den Comments geschrieben haben, nicht so ganz klar war.
Wenn du eine legendäre...
Tja, wie heißt das Ding auf Deutsch?
Edelstein, nee.
So einen Upgrade für so einen ältesten Rift kaufst.
Also so ein Pay to Win Upgrade Item.
Da steht ja dann da so nach dem Motto, hey alle, wenn du Pech hast,
alle so und so viel, ich glaube alle 50 oder so Sachen ist ein Fünfer-Jam garantiert.
Es ist kein Fünfer-Jam garantiert.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das steht so da.
Aber was in Wirklichkeit garantiert ist, ist ein Jam,
was die Chance hat, als Fünf-Star-Jam zu droppen.
Mit allen anderen Sachen haben deine Jams gar nicht die Chance, Fünf-Star, sondern maximal Zwei-Star zu droppen.
Nicht, du kriegst, das steht da, du kriegst ein Fünf-Star-Jam, das stimmt nicht.
Du kriegst die Chance auf ein Fünf-Star-Jam.
Nur den Unlock.
Und die Chance ist dann, dass du es wirklich bekommst bei einem Prozent oder so.
Da werden uns bessere Werte, neue Eigenschaften und die sind beide zu verhalten.
Hast du Diablo 3 gespielt?
Ja, gar nicht so wenig, aber ich muss sagen, es hat mich nicht komplett überzeugt,
deswegen bin ich auch auf Diablo 4 nicht sonderlich gespannt.
Diablo 2, Beste, immer noch.
Diablo 2 ist eines der besten Games, die je gemacht wurden.
...
Nö, das ist nicht illegal.
egal und dadurch dass du wie gesagt rechtlichen sachen keine ahnung ob das stimmt aber es klingt
logisch also in diablo ist ja so du kannst rein cashen und dann musst du so ein mini dungeon machen
von ein paar minuten und am ende kriegst du die belohnung und dadurch dass du nicht einfach das
item anklickst und random meist müssen sie nicht so sehr auf die wahrscheinlichkeiten hinweisen
weil wenn du dir ein item kaufst und du öffnest das und es ist zu einem prozent was drinne dann
musst du ja mittlerweile diese diese chancen angegeben kriegen wenn du allerdings ein upgrade
item kaufst für einen dungeon und du dann den dungeon machst und am ende tropft random was
was du beeinflusst durch die upgrade items dann musst du nicht angeben was das an chancen bringt
und es ist halt einfach nur ganz knallhart kalkuliert pvp relevant obendrein natürlich
auch für die pve ranglisten wir sagen ja gut pve ranglisten kann ja keiner spiel außer es
reicht wie bekommen wir die jetzt wir erbreiten sie in ältesten portalen das sind so fünf minütige
embleme hieß das heißt das auf deutsch und in die setzen wir vor dem stamm das meine ich
weder seltene embleme kostenlos oder legendäre embleme für circa 2 euro 50 pro stück ein und
die unterschiede zwischen den ja und das ist das was ich meine also hier ist es ja so wenn
du dir diese upgrade items kaufst dann hast du also nicht nicht dass der wenn du dir wenn du
das hier kaufst also wenn du dir die die die legendären embleme kauf dann ist es ja irgendwie
so dass du alle 50 oder so ein drop bekommst den garantierten edelstein drop und da hat man halt
nur die chance auf ein fünfstar gemm also du hast nur ein prozent chance dass aber du hast
die chance dass es rollt den traurigen kleinen gratis emblemen und den ehrbaren edlen erhabenen
legendären kostenpflichtigen die sind gewaltig ja es gibt drei haupt und es gibt leute die
verteidigen das gelbe immer noch bis aufs blut ich kann es nicht verstehen erwartet ich frage
mich manchmal sind das von blizzard bezahlte leute kann ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen
weil die bezahlen wahrscheinlich nicht so 3 hat leute oder sind es einfach einfach dumm besten
edelsteine die das verteidigen ich verstehe es nicht nur mit den echt geld emblemen blizzard
gibt die offiziellen drop chancen sogar im spiel an ein oder es sind leute oder es sind leute die
krass reingepayt haben und jetzt festgestellt haben fax lohnt sich ja gar nicht und sich das
jetzt irgendwie schön reden müssen emblem also das kostenlose hat eine ach moment moment das
andere kommt ja noch prozent schon ein stern ein stern ein stein zu droppen das ist alles aber die
edelsteine gehen bis zu fünf sterne hoch und die droppen nur mit legendären emblemen es gibt jetzt
alibi metoden wie ihr theoretisch auch free to play da rankommen könnt zum beispiel den markt
oder das crafting aber ja aber das ist alles so absurd gedrosselt ja du kriegst kaum was kaum
eine rolle spielen zum beispiel gibt es den hildhändler der für ja das kenne ich haltet
euch fest halten euch fest embleme verkauft pass pass auf wie viel du kaufen kannst in der
woche passt mal auf pass auf und zwar exakt oder am tag ich bin mir nicht sicher im monat was im
monat sogar pack alda im monat im monat oder du kaufst und jetzt schaut euch mal die offizie
ich dachte eigentlich war einst die woche einem legendären emblem an es wird garantiert ein
edelstein droppen aber nur zu ach so ist das so 5 prozent einer von den besten mit fünf
sterne potential und ja richtig potenzial jetzt kommt die eigentliche dropprate hoffe ich mal
zum beispiel zwei von fünf oder drei von fünf sterne droppen ein fünf von fünf edelstein
droppt nur zu sagt doch ein prozent in prozent und zwar um das nur mal klar zu machen ein prozent
von 4,5 prozent sind also ein fünf von fünf edelstein das sind 0,045 prozent pro legendärem
emblem ein streamer krasses value was man da bekommt es mal auf die probe gestellt und
wollte so lange echt geld rifts laufen bis er einen solchen edelstein gefunden hat und
zum zeitpunkt dieses videos zum zeitpunkt der aufnahme hat er fast 6000 euro reingeballert
wie viel hat er weiß jemand wie viel er mittlerweile hat das videos ja auch schon zwei tage alt
und hat er mittlerweile ein und noch keinen bekommen nun eine grundausrüstung von ein
paar low-level edelsteine bescheuert alle so lächerlich alles und dass das leute noch
verteidigen aber es ist erstaunlich wenig muss ich sagen ansonsten hat blizzard ja immer
die standard fanboys die alles abfeiern aber das hat noch weniger verteidiger ist dadurch
sogar wieder fair weil der pay to win spieler den besten edelstein ja auch nicht kriegt
selbst wenn er 1000 euro reinbuttern so kann man es auch sehen das bringt uns zum zweiten
großen unterschied zwischen gratis spieler und zahlenden spielern man braucht berge
und die kriegt man realistischerweise nur wenn man zahlt denn jeden edelstein kann man
in zehn stufen aufwerten ja man muss den kram am ende am ende ist es noch heftiger
wenn du das dann fertig hast musst du noch ob das glaube ich nicht mal das einzige ist
gibt es noch ein awakening bonus wo du deine items noch mal upgraden kannst weitere boni
frei und erhöht auch die chance auf bessere beute dafür muss man aber andere jedes item
wohlgemerkt teurer um einen einstern edelstein auf rang 2 aufzuleveln brauche ich erstmal
nur einen anderen edelstein des gleichen levels einfach für rang 3 brauche ich dann aber
schon fünf edelstein macht das ist kein game das ist kein game das ist reines reines random
meises random meises loot boxen öffnen in einem gameplay gewandt das dir vortäuschen
soll als gebe es ein gameplay und das geht immer weiter hoch bis ich auf rang 10 schließlich
sogar 50 brauche und das sind nur das wusste ich auch nicht am btf bei drei sternen geht
noch mehr für rang 2 mit 50 edelstein macht und bei 5 die sind so genau habe ich mich
dann nicht mit beschäftigt wieder mehr edelstein macht wert sie zählen soviel wie 32 wisst
ihr was ich bei sowas auch immer abartig finde dass diese spiele immer 30 verschiedene upgrade
systeme haben und das ist normal bei mobile games und warum ist das bei mobile games so
ja mobile games möchten damit content vortäuschen der eigentlich gar nicht da ist guckt euch
mal diese nur nach 15 städte aufbau mobile games ansicht da gibt die haben alle 5 6 10
verschiedene systeme und es sieht immer so aus als machst du irgendwas aber in wirklich
kein machst du eigentlich gar nichts was hier genauso ist einstern steine aber grundlegend
und das ist vor allem dass du gar nicht erkennst wie du progress machst wann du progress machst
ob du progress machst es soll immer so aussehen es soll dir das einfach vortäuschen und das
ist halt nicht das was ich von einem random faktor in diablo erwarte in diablo erwarte
ich natürlich dass das spiel random meist ist ich sage jetzt einfach ich keine ahnung
ich kenne das video nicht ich sage das was ich zu denke in diablo erwarte ich natürlich
dass das random meist ist also random faktor ist ein großer punkt von diablo aber es ist
nicht dieser random faktor dort das ist was was was komplett anderes um sechs steine
zumal dort auch jeder die gleiche chance hat aber wie wir schon gesehen haben
wie diesen scheiß jemand verteidigen kann das ist mir komplett unverständlich wir hatten
auch ein komplett das ist illusionierten der hat bei mir in den kommentaren behauptet
max ich bin free to play spieler und top 5 der rangliste da wollte ich gar nicht drauf
antworten da ich mir gedacht also das ist so offensichtlicher schwachsinn keckel ja dacu
danke für den sub
um am ende zehn edelstein herauszubekommen esmen gold zeigt hier sehr schön den unterschied
das ist der luxuriöse
guckt euch die augenbrauen an das bin ich bei esmen gold immer am besten mit seinen augenbrauen
macht das sieht aus ist das traurige leben eines free to play spieler
die free to play chancen sind so minimal und es würde in der praxis so ewig dauern seinen
charakter auszumachsen dass man hier nicht mehr von pay to progress reden kann weil dafür
müsste der progress ja irgendwo in irgendeiner form überhaupt noch ja aber wie ich ja wie
gesagt ich finde eh das habe ich aber mir auch im video gesagt ich finde das ist eh so eine
rein philosophische frage ob man es jetzt pay to win pay to progress oder pay to wie
auch immer nennt
es geht darum wie sie dem spiel implementiert ist wie du es nennst ist ja eigentlich zweitrangig
ich weiß dass die leute und ich denke mal deswegen stellt das hier auch so klar sich
gerne an irgendwelchen formulierungen aufhängen aber wie du es nennst macht ja im endeffekt
überhaupt kein unterschied für das was es ist
es ist einfach nur pay es ist noch nicht mal pay to weil du kriegst ja noch nicht mal was
und das ist er nicht deswegen ist das hier pures direktes pay to win es kursieren die
verschiedensten rechnungen wie viel zeit oder geld man reinstecken muss von jahren bis
jahrzehnten von zehntausend dollar bis hunderttausend dollar in jedem fall ist es absurd nun ist
blizzard aber manchmal sogar großzügig einen einzigen stellt euch mal vor jetzt mal ohne
scheiß stellt euch mal vor ihr spielt dieses spiel free to play für 10 jahre was ihr müsst
damit ihr ein bisschen progress macht und dann wird die server abgeschaltet das stelle
ich mir geil vor den siegen der würdigen den könnt ihr sogar direkt kaufen und immerhin
auf drei sterne und rang 4 also so in die mitte immerhin haben die nicht gesagt man
kann sich keine items kaufen also es ist ja kein es ist ja kein item es ist ja ein juwel
160 ach ein schnapper 160 euro item kein ding ja aber jetzt nehmen wir mal an ihr habt
entweder das soll mal irgendjemand noch mal ankommen mit das ist kein pay to win das
ist alles so affig diese diskussion also wer das verteidigt der möchte wahrscheinlich
dass alle spiele mit so einem kack verseucht werden verkauft oder euer halbes leben in
diablo immortal reingegrindet und ihr habt jetzt sechs edelsteine fünf sterne auf rang
10 dann habt ihr es geschafft wahrscheinlich nicht oder wahrscheinlich nicht dann geht's
nämlich erst richtig los denn jetzt kommen wir zu unterschied nummer drei zwischen dem
kleinen free to play bauern und dem zahlenden kunden wenn ihr einen edelstein tatsächlich
mal auf stufe wenn du wenn du leute sehen willst dies verteidigen dann wahrscheinlich
haben die was auch hier drunter aber so ein bisschen dann guck unter meinem video oder
gucken in dem einen und unter diesem reinen pay video von trimex leute es ist so es ist
so pains jam die leute ist es ist so pains ich will es jetzt nicht aufmachen es ist die
leute ich kann es mir nicht geben es ist das schmerz beim zugucken noch erwecken das verbessert
seine fähigkeit und das genau das ist das was ich meinte so 15 euro das wusste ich
nicht dass du das nur kaufen kannst ich dachte es gibt bestimmt auch irgendwelche drei jahre
gefahmt dass das geht aber ja das muss man dann auch noch machen also am ende und ich
glaube jedes item ich glaube noch nicht mal dass das irgendwie alles glaubt das ist für
jedes item 50 euro für die komplette ausrüstung und dann könnt ihr in jeden eurer edelsteine
noch mal mehrere andere edelsteine ein socken die alle noch mal hochleveln müsst auf genau
die gleiche weise wie davor nur jetzt noch mal ein vielfaches wisst ihr wisst ihr das
ist halt die reine mobile game glücksspiel mechanik eine sache die diablo ausgemacht
ich sage mal zumindest diablo 2 ausgemacht hat ist die kombination aus builds items und
random faktor es geht nicht darum dass es ein reines glücksspiel ist es ist die art
des random science was diablo 2 ausgemacht hat du hast verschiedene klassen du hattest
verschiedene builds das ist hier alles wohl sehr rudimentär nur für hat nur vorhanden
und natürlich spielt der random faktor mit aber in diablo 2 konntest du einfach richtig
hart progress machen wenn du magic find runs gemacht hast und das war für alle gleich
und es ist nicht so dass das irgendwie künstlich getrosselt hat so nach dem motto du hast heute
schon fünf runs gemacht bei einem sechsten run kriegst du jetzt allerdings abgezogene
job shows oder sowas sowas ich es ist so bitter ich meine unter dem strich hat wenn es wenn
es ums geld verdienen geht ja hat blizzard das wahrscheinlich gar nicht falsch gemacht
blizzard hat wahrscheinlich eine gute entscheidung getroffen zum geld verdienen also besser
gesagt die bvl körper bei activision haben eine gute entscheidung getroffen das was
ich allerdings mir bei blizzard games immer vorgestellt habe zumindest früher letzten
jahren immer weniger ist es halt einfach gar nicht dieses sanctum wo man sich ressourcen
erfahrend und seine werte aufzurüsten und auch hier kann man natürlich kisten mit echt
geld öffnen es ist einfach total bizarr wie viel geld man in dieses spiel reinbuttern
kann und wie es sich tatsächlich zu einem sehr großen teil auch wirklich auf die stärke
so entspannungsmusik im hintergrund hier auswirkt selbst im pvp nun kann man natürlich sagen
und das stimmte zu einem gewissen teil man muss ja nicht man kann tatsächlich wenn man
einfach nur die kampagne durchspielen will die kampagne also es dürfte wahrscheinlich
das schlechteste in diesem game aller zeiten sein die diablo kampagnen waren jetzt noch
nie wie soll ich sagen sonderlich episch will ich nicht sagen waren sie auf gewisser
art und weise schon die war das noch nie ausgefeilt oder so das war eigentlich immer vorwand
um dahin zu gehen zu killen zu leveln bessere items zum nächsten zu killen so aber die hatten
immer eine eine epische tragweite sage ich das trifft am besten die waren zwar simpel
gestrickt aber die hatten immer eigentlich eine coole erzählweise diablo 3 fand ich
schon nicht mehr so gut ehrlich gesagt rede ich eigentlich nur von diablo 2 diablo 1 war
alles noch sehr rudimentär das hatte quasi keinerlei erzählung keine wirkliche story
außer weil hat zwischen den zeilen gelesen ein bisschen ja und diablo 2 war halt cool
in allen bereichen wie gesagt ich bin immer auch damals als der besten spiel die gemacht
wurden entspannt machen mit den edelsteinen die man free to play bekommt da braucht man
überhaupt nichts erst wenn man wirklich knallhart pvp oder ranglisten machen will dann empfiehlt
sich eine gewisse echtgeld investition wenn man wirklich mithalten will aber ich zum beispiel
mir sind ranglisten schnurz mir ist pvp auch schnurz mir kann das eigentlich egal das ist
ich gehe davon aus er sagt jetzt es ist mir aber nicht egal aber ich möchte vorher noch
was sagen das kann auch den leuten die einfach nur just for fun spielen nicht egal sein weil
dieses game explizit designed wurde auf money das ist nicht für gute spielbarkeit designt
oder dass man dass man spielspaß hat es ist dafür die sein zum geld machen das heißt
es trifft selbstverständlich auch die leute die das einfach nur just for fun spielen ein
gutes beispiel dafür ist wo man es glaube ich offensichtlich sieht ihr erinnert euch
doch bestimmt noch an battlefront 2 und die helden ja wo ausgerechnet wurde man muss irgendwie
keine ahnung 400 stunden kreinden um irgendwie das weder oder luke skywalker freizuschalten
und warum ist das so gewesen ganz klar die leute wollten dass der crying so hart ist dass
du lieber geld ausgibst also das heißt sobald die entscheidung quasi money first getroffen
ist sind alle weiteren entscheidungen wie man dieses game aufzieht beziehungsweise wie
man dieses game balanced nur noch darauf ausgerichtet und nicht mehr um einen ordentlichen spielfluss
zu bieten um ein ordentliches gameplay zu bieten sondern einfach nur wie kriegt man möglichst
viel kohle raus deswegen mag eben mag ich auch abo modelle ohne dass es das noch mit
in game shop gibt ja aber modelle sind gut da weiß ein hersteller es laufen ihm nicht
morgen die ganzen leute weg weil von einem monat auf den anderen kündigkeit für den
hersteller ist es relativ safe und ich weiß ich bezahle meine abo gebühr und ich bin damit
genau so gut und so schlecht gestellt wie alle anderen auch deswegen mag ich mmos mit
abos leider ist das out und es sagen immer viele leute null warum sollte ich monatsgebühr
für mmos bezahlen ich persönlich bin da mal bin der meinung mmos im abo modell ist das
beste modell für den hersteller und für die spieler dass es jetzt sachen wie world of
warcraft gibt mit monats abo und in game shop und bisschen payment ist ein komplettes unding
das will ich nicht gut reden das finde ich genauso kacke aber monats abo monats abo ist
das die beste form für online games wenn ihr mich fragt das macht halt nur keiner mehr
weil die leute nicht mehr bereit sind zu bezahlen weil sie sich lieber von free to play sachen
vor gaukeln lassen sie würden was free bekommen sei ist es aber nicht ist es aber nicht genau
und das will ich auch noch begründen denn das hat drei gründe nummer eins ein solches
design macht das spiel auch für gratis richtig schlechter richtig ja so ist es immer grind
es gibt leute wollen das aber nicht einsehen auch oft mal genau so ist es und eher langwierig
logisch und auch in früheren teilen hatten nur die wenigsten spieler voll world of warcraft
hat nur noch 2000 subs quatsch im leben nicht 2000 subs da könnten die dicht machen
karaktere weil das einfach ein heftiges zeitinvestment war aber der grind hat von anfang bis ende
egal wie weit ich entschlossen habe ihn zu gehen immer spaß gemacht weil er immer wieder
belohnungen das stimmt weil ich immer wieder erfolgserlebnisse im großen und im kleinen
hatte coole neue items coole neue fähigkeiten das ist das macht maurice richtig gut dieses
argument zu bringen ist schwierig für leute die sagen wir kein diablo 2 gespielt haben
weil die kennen halt so viele free to play games das ist schwierig nachzuvollziehen
für solche leute glaube ich die sagen doch wieso random factor gab es doch immer und
wieso wenn ich payen will da muss nicht payen es ist aber nicht so all das hat spaß gemacht
hat motiviert es hat es macht gut dass diablo das architektisch ist wenn man an das wort
ludspirale denkt es musste dich immer zu motivieren und der unterschied zu diablo immortal ist
dass dieses spiel per definition exakt so justiert ist dass es dich so wenig belohnt
wie es kann dass du gerade noch nicht deinstallier sondern eher gelten so habe ich so habe ich
da der hat komplett recht so habe ich da gar nicht drüber nachgedacht bis jetzt das ist
aber das ist was was mir so ähnlich im kopf rumgeschwebt ist weil ich aber nicht klar
hätte so formulieren können ja das trifft ziemlich gute lohnungen zu bekommen und wenn
du das dann machst kriegst du immer noch nichts zufriedenstellendes weil das spiel
ja will dass du immer mehr und immer mehr ausgibst man merkt das an jeder ecke im direkten
vergleich mit früheren diabolos ist hier alles gedrosselt die rifts werfen free to
play kaum was relevantes ab selbst während die leute die sagen du kannst es ja auch ohne
ohne geldeinsatz spielen oder die leute sind auch selbst dran schuld wenn sie geld reinhauen
das ist ähnlich wie wenn du sagen würdest die oma die vom enkel die von irgendwelchen
betrüger mit dem enkeltrick gescampt wurde ist ja auch selber dran schuld weil sie hätte
es ja auch erkennen können klar jetzt kann man argumentieren das eine ist ja wirklich
betrug und das andere nicht aber der einzige unterschied ist diablo immortal ist kein betrug
in dem fall weil du erst mal ganz viele agbs abhaken musst das ist das zwischen illegal
im klücksspiel und dem liegt eigentlich nur dass du die agbs abhakt wirst du schon ständig
unterbrochen dass du die story erst weiterspielen darfst wenn du ein paar weitere level gegrindet
hast und später paragon ist ebenfalls gedrosselt wenn du zu schnell leveln solltest du hast
viel seltener irgendwelche coolen erfolgsmomente irgendwelche coolen funde das ist ja auch
so was mit dem drosseln die wollen halt dass keiner vorne weg level und die wollen dass
sie die hinterher sind schnell aufholen warum naja weil die wollen dass sie gut reinpähen
und das ist auch was das hat das hast du mit einem abo modell nicht mit einem abo modell
ist alles genauso schnell wie das vom game designer designed wurde und du wirst nicht
künstlich gedrosselt du wirst auch nicht künstlich gebufft es sei denn es macht aus spielmechanischer
sicht sinn zum beispiel wenn es irgendwelche pvp sachen gibt wo man erst ab 50 teilnehmen
kann das spiele ich schon drei jahre raus dass man sagt ok neue spieler dürfen ab 20 einsteigen
irgendwie sowas ja aber dann ist nicht das geld die entscheidung sondern dass es für
das endgame am besten ist all das ist zurückgefahren reduziert gedrosselt viel häufiger hast du
das gefühl du hast jetzt eigentlich gar nichts cooles bekommen du hast einfach nur gegrindet
um des grindens willen und du hast es nicht optimal gemacht weil du hast kein geld ausgegeben
außerdem ist alles möglichst und durchschaubar hinterhaufen weise verschwinden das ist aber
bei allen mobile scam games leider so mobile gaming ist komplette abschaum ich meine ich
bin jetzt kein riesiger apple fan ja aber was apple mit ihrem apple apple wie heißt das
game bundle akade game bundle ich weiß es nicht hab mir das nie gekauft aber was ich
dort vom ansatz her gut finde ist du kaufst das und dann sind diese spiele da drin eben
können diese spiele die da drin sind und damit geld verdienen halt eben nicht entwickelt
werden auf irgendwelche pay to win aspekte sondern eben einfach nur auf ich möchte ein
gutes handy game machen aus diesem gesichtspunkt finde ich dieses apple wie heißt es apple
akade oder so ja deswegen finde ich das vom ansatz her eigentlich ganz ganz sinnvoll was
die da haben du bezahlst monats aber und bekommst jede menge spiele ich habe keine ahnung ob
das gute games sind oder das ist bestimmt auch ein paar scam pay to win sachen vielleicht
dabei ich weiß es nicht aber insgesamt besteht halt dort eher die chance dass du sagen kannst
ja die spiele entwickeln wir nicht auf maximales pay to win oder free to play shop gedöns
sondern die spiele entwickeln wir darauf hin dass es ein gutes game ist weil die leute
brauchen ein anreiz das aber zu kaufen und uns das geld zu geben und für kack spiele
kauft keiner das aber so haben beide was davon um zu verschleiern wie wenig du eigentlich
bekommst damit du bloß nicht kapiert was ist jetzt eigentlich echt geld was nicht wo ist
pay to win wo nicht welche währung bringt was das spiel ist nicht darauf ausgelegt dich
zu motivieren und eine befriedigende belohnungskurve zu entfalten wenn du nicht zahlst und gesagt
selbst wenn du zahlst eigentlich auch nicht wirklich und das ist der unterschied zwischen
spaßig im grind und diablo immortal und das ist alles kein versagen der entwickler das
ist ja 22 42 sind wir durch den grundnummer 2 warum mich diese pay to win mechanik stört
obwohl sie mich selbst nicht mal wirklich direkt betrifft weil ich wie gesagt an pvp und rang
listen nicht so interessiert bin es zielt auf verwundbare spiele ab wunderbar auf den
punkt gebracht hat dass die june position die legendären embleme sind ja jett muss
ich was zu sagen ich finde das prinzipiell auch nicht schlimm wenn man geld im spiel
ausgeben kann was mir auf uns aber das sind dann einfach games die könnte ich links liegen
lassen ja aber da geht es mir tatsächlich ein bisschen wie moris das problem ist das
schleicht sich immer mehr rein in alle möglichen games das ist das was mir ehrlich gesagt
am meisten auf den sack geht er wenn man sagen können pay to win game juckt mich nicht lass
ich liegen ist es aber nicht es verseucht zunehmend immer mehr alle möglichen games spiele wo
man früher nie dran gedacht hätte dass sie einen shop haben wie ver ist übrigens kein
gutes beispiel fifa war schon trash in der hinsicht stand schon immer seit es diese ganzen
online handelsdinger gibt als fährdinger es sind getarnte lootboxen du kaufst sie dir
genau dann machst du den dungeon und dann ja und wisst ihr warum man den dungeon machen
muss ich hoffe dass das ist damit die nicht unter unter die lootbox regel fallen kriegst
und eine zufällige belohnung aber letztlich spielen sie genauso mit glücksspielmechanismen
aber jebaited dass dass sie nicht unter glücksspiel also nicht unter lootboxen fallen und deswegen
sind sie auch gefährlich für leute die anfällig für solche suchtmechanismen sind und das
spiel bedient sich all der psychologischen tricks die wir inzwischen zur genüge kennen
das starterpaket mit 800 prozent value die fakewährung um den echten kaufpreis zu verschleiern
der tägliche log in bonus der euch jeden tag in den shop führt wir wissen längst
dass all sowas wissenschaftlich fundierte psychologische manipulation ist in die wahrscheinlich
mehr hirnschmalz geschlossen geflossen ist als in spiel ja so wird sein nummer 3 und
das ist jetzt der banalste und zugegeben auch subjektivste aber ok ich ich predicte mal
er findet schade dass ich blödsinn für sowas hergibt oder sowas ich bring ihn trotzdem
an es ist einfach alles so unglaublich unsympathisch ok wenn jemand ein angebot macht hat er aber
auch recht mit so wenig bietet und dafür so viel unsympathisch das ist eigentlich ein
richtig guter begriff für das was ich über die was ich bei den meisten mobile games empfinde
wenn ich das im app store vorgeschlagen bekomme und ich mache es vielleicht doch mal auf ich
denke mir das sieht so unsympathisch aus so krepp krepp nach müll dass ich im leben nicht
spielen werde dann fühle ich mich doch irgendwo in meiner intelligenz beleidigt das kann hier
im chat nicht passieren gebraucht wagenhändler zu viel hrq vw käfer zum preis eines rolls
royce andrehen will klar ich muss es nicht kaufen das ist absolut korrekt aber junge
trotzdem hast du mich komplett für bescheuert blizzard ist wie der alte schulfreund der
sich nach jahren wieder meldet um dir seine versicherung an zettler klar blizzard übertrieben
aber die werden damit richtig krass kohle machen was bitter ist weil das dadurch noch
mehr einwirkung auf zug auswirkung auf zukünftige games haben wird das verseucht immer mehr
alle möglichen games das ist das was mir am meisten auf den kecks geht zu drehen und
du sitzt da und denkst dir es gibt kaum noch neue triple a games ohne irgendwelche shops
und payment scheiße und ja das denke ich auch von blizzard sind sie aber nicht mehr
zu sehen aber das alle guckt euch besser weg sein an die machen es gescheit dass selbst
ich einräumen muss unterm strich hat blizzard wahrscheinlich alles richtig gemacht ja fürs
geld bin ja nicht doof das hier ist ein kampf gegen windmühlen und immortal wird höchst
wahrscheinlich mehr geld machen als diablo 4 ja das ist wahrscheinlich gaming markt und
da sind alte fans wie wir halt egal rotz mobile weg was diablo immortal macht ist im mobile
bereich völlig normal oder sogar noch harmlos es geht tatsächlich noch deutlich schlimmer
aber es geht auch besser wenn man zum beispiel ein beispiel will wie eine große weg sein
firma ein beliebtes großes spiel würde voll und loll aufs handy gebracht hat dann sollte
man sich mal league of legends wild rift von riot anschauen dass einfach tatsächlich ein
gutes spiel ist ohne all diesen unsinn und selbst bei blizzard selbst half stone blizzard
macht enorm viel gelten auf stone und ich sage nicht dass half stone immer sport lull
super 100 prozent kundenfreundlich ist was die monetarisierung angeht aber stellt euch
mal vor in half stone könnte man mit den gratis erspielten boostern nur gewöhnliche karten
kriegen und alles darüber gäbe es nur in echt geld boostern oder vielleicht eben in
einem pro monat den du gratis bekommst wie absurd wäre denn das aber das ist das modell
von diablo immortal das ist der unterschied zwischen gratis emblemen und legendären emblemen
also selbst blizzard hat schon gezeigt dass man mit einem mobile spiel immer noch sehr
gut geld machen kann mit einem zumindest nicht ganz so grenzenlosen schwarzen pay to win
loch wie es diablo immortal sein möchte und dennoch laut finanzbericht von activision
blizzard der lehrer sieht irgendwie äußerst mitgenommen aus in dem video lässt sich im
grunde zusammenfassen mit chat was ist denn eigentlich also chat sagt was ist denn bei
games eigentlich los gottmüll, battlefieldmüll, diablo müll wisst ihr was los ist zu wenig
game designer die noch wissen was sie machen oder man sie machen lässt und zu viele bwl
stonks leute und zu wenig games designer die ihren eigenen shit überhaupt noch spielen
wollen es ist einfach money ist los genau alles doof außer candy crush also ist es auf
eine absurde art und weise ja sogar nachvollziehbar warum sie mehr in diese richtung gehen warum
auch viel aufwand für leute wie mich machen die ihnen dann ganz einfach weil früher bei
blizzard leute gesessen haben die gesagt haben den mist den wir hier programmieren das muss
was sein was ich selber gerne spielen möchte deswegen die haben früher nicht die games
gemacht rein jetzt weil sie gesagt haben wir wollen irgendwie top 50 millionäre werden
oder so sondern weil sie spiele machen wollten die sie selber gerne spielen wollen und das
hat man auch gesehen die haben sich damals für alt die world of warcraft entwickelt
haben die haben sich top everquest raider geholt warum weil sie gesagt haben die wissen
was gutes endgame ist ja was gutes immer mo design ist damals gab es ja auch nicht
wie santa mehr und was ich mir damals 2000 noch was gedacht habe als ich so als ich relativ
viele mmo viel mmo gespielt habe was ich mir ausgemalt habe wie geil mmos 2020 sein müssen
mit den neuen möglichkeiten es gibt es es gibt keine gescheite neuen mmos und was rauskommt
ist scheiße und die dies noch gibt sind naja auch nicht unbedingt haben sich zum besseren
entwickeln so schlimm und das soziale aspekt so dass ein mmo ein massive multiplayer online
gut online ist aber der multiplayer aspekt der gefällt auch immer weiter weg sich euro
für ein spiel geben wollen und vielleicht dann auch noch trotzdem rumnörgeln wenn du
auch mit weniger aufwand ein spiel die leute sind heute halt auch total anspruchslos geworden
und reden sich den größten scheiß schön heute machen kann es die tausende euro reinballern
werden sich dabei nicht mal beschweren werden es ist nachvollziehbar irgendwo und alles
was blizzard bislang wirklich fertig alle in dem video war ihr eigener anspruch das bestmögliche
spiel was was sie selber spielen wollen haben sie offensichtlich schon vor einer ganzen
weile abgelegt und das ist wahrscheinlich sogar schlau und konsequent von ihnen aber
es ist trotzdem furchtbar schade denn man sieht bei diablo immortal mit einem anderen
ansatz es hätte so viel mehr sein können weil es ist nicht so als würde da nichts
drinstecken es ist durchaus technisch für ein mobile diablo ziemlich beeindruckend
es macht auch durchaus laune sich so ab und an mal da auf dem handy durch den riff zu
ballern es hätte was anderes sein können ja das war mal wieder ein richtiges gute laune
video von eurem experten für die schönen seiten des gaming schreibt mir gern was
ihr von diablo immortal haltet findet ihr ich bin zu hart damit ins gericht gegangen
oder seid ihr auch von der monetarisierung enttäuscht und wenn ihr mich live leiden
sehen wollt dann schaut doch auch mal auf meinem twitch kanal moris weber vorbei wo
ich aktuell fünf tage die woche streamen unter anderem um die und da macht das mal diablo
immortal mit der ist wirklich fertig in dem video am schluss spielen da auch schönere
sachen schlacht und mittelerde ja aber da hat es gut getroffen wieder deswegen gucke
ich die videos von moris gerne genau ehrenmann richtige ehrenmann ja leute schon spät betke
time umar müde ich muss jetzt auf wir sehen uns macht's gut leute bis zum nächsten stream
vielleicht morgen schon mal gucken bis denn zu